Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, episode 29. CUDA and OpenCL. Take it away, Patrick. So I'm a little under the weather. So if I sound stuffy or terrible, I'm gonna
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供赞助。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 29 期。CUDA 和 OpenCL。Patrick，开始吧。我有点感冒，所以如果我听起来鼻音很重或者声音很糟糕，我会把原因归咎于此。
blame that. Yeah, I dragged him kicking and screaming into the Programming Throwdown studio to record this episode. The studio? Wait. The studio. Am I taking too much medicine? Alright, so I do have an opening topic, and then maybe I'll lose my voice already, and
是啊，我把他连拖带拽地拉进了 Programming Throwdown 的录音室来录制这一期节目。录音室？等等。录音室。我是不是药吃多了？好吧，我有一个开场话题，然后可能我还没说完嗓子就哑了，
be quiet for the rest of the episode. Hey, stop cheering. All right. So I link a website here in the show notes, origamitesolations.com. But more specifically, my mom was in town to visit, and she likes doing puzzles or whatever. I don't know how I got on it. My mom likes doing – maybe it's a mom thing. Maybe it's a connection with moms and puzzles.
剩下的节目就只能保持安静了。嘿，别欢呼。好吧。我在节目说明里放了一个网站链接，origamitesolations.com。更具体地说，我妈妈来城里看我，她喜欢玩拼图之类的东西。我不知道我是怎么接触到这个的。我妈妈喜欢玩——也许这是妈妈们的共同爱好。也许妈妈们和拼图之间有什么联系。
I mean, I think it's – I like puzzles as well. I just don't have patience for them or that's what it is a connection with like like you know for example like like my parents are close to retirement my dad's already retired so they have plenty of time that we don't have because we're uh working kids all that stuff yeah so i think we could probably be puzzle masters in 40 years and how many 30 years 40 years 10 early retirement oh all right it's a puzzle if you can solve that puzzle let me know yeah yeah uh i'll sell a book yeah that's right um so anyways so so she was out to visit us and uh we somehow i don't remember i think i had some origami paper i had found at a store or whatever and i was like oh off and on throughout you know childhood i had tried doing this amazing art of
我的意思是，我觉得——我也喜欢拼图。只是我没有耐心，或者说这确实是一种联系，比如，你知道，我的父母快退休了，我爸爸已经退休了，所以他们有我们没有的充足时间，因为我们这些孩子都在忙着工作等等。是的，所以我认为我们 40 年后可能成为拼图大师，或者 30 年、40 年后，提前退休。哦，好吧，如果你能解开这个谜题，请告诉我。是的，我会卖一本书。是的，没错。嗯，总之，她来看我们，我不知道怎么回事，我想我当时在商店里找到了一些折纸纸，我就想，哦，断断续续地，你知道，童年时期我曾尝试过这种神奇的艺术，
folding paper and never been very good at it and recently i found some and tried it and decided i was going to search on youtube and surprisingly enough youtube is an excellent teacher for origami right sometimes now sometimes people do stuff they're like oh you just do this and then they like put their hands in front of the paper as they do some crazy trick awesome voodoo stuff. And then it's just as puzzling. But for, like, straightforward things and for the most part, rather than looking at the diagram, you know, it's a really useful thing. So my mom and I started doing some origami in the evening as, like, something to do as opposed to just sitting and watching TV or whatever. And she was really, really excited about it and really excited to watch youtube videos um and see like oh this is
折纸，但我从来都不擅长。最近我找到了一些，试了一下，决定在 YouTube 上搜索，令人惊讶的是，YouTube 是学习折纸的绝佳老师。有时候，人们做的时候会说，哦，你只要这样做，然后他们就在纸前把手放上去，做一些疯狂的技巧，像巫术一样。然后这变得更加令人困惑。但对于简单明了的事情，在大多数情况下，比起看图解，这确实是一个非常有用的东西。所以我和我妈妈晚上开始折纸，作为一种消遣，而不是只是坐着看电视什么的。她对此非常非常兴奋，也非常喜欢看 YouTube 视频，
really helpful like i never knew how to do this before or whatever so we folded some animals and some complicated shapes and some simple shapes it was a lot of fun but this website origami tessellations.com i had come across probably a couple years ago and the guy here i believe his first name is eric i won't try to pronounce his last name uh he he does uh tessellation origami which is just like you would think tessellation is like the same shape triangles triangles or squares oh that's right it's shifted around and of course once you have triangles you can do hexagons and so it's basically you first fold the paper into pre-creasing it with like let's say a bunch of squares then you do a set of maneuvers probably not using the right word anyways to fold those into something else or like
看到这些觉得，哦，这真的很有帮助，我以前从来不知道怎么做这个，等等。所以我们折了一些动物、一些复杂的形状和一些简单的形状，这很有趣。但我几年前偶然发现了这个网站 origami tessellations.com，这里的那个人，我相信他名字叫 Eric，我就不试着读他的姓了，他做的是折纸镶嵌，就像你想象的那样，镶嵌就是同样的形状，三角形或正方形，哦，没错，它是错位的。当然，一旦你有三角形，你就可以做六边形，所以基本上你先通过预折痕把纸折成，比如说一堆正方形，然后你做一系列的操作，可能用词不当，总之，把它们折成别的东西，或者
also a repeated pattern or a new shape and i just find it really interesting because normal origami is cool but sometimes you know it's like how many different ways can you fold a penguin well they don't look that much like a penguin or whatever. But this is more like artistic and abstract in a way because you're not making specifically something that looks like an animal. You could be making something that is just beautiful for the repetition of it. So I folded one. Oh, yeah, I'm looking at some of these pictures now. It looks pretty awesome.
也是一种重复的图案或新的形状。我觉得这真的很有趣，因为普通的折纸很酷，但有时你知道，就像你能折多少种不同的企鹅？嗯，它们看起来不太像企鹅什么的。但这更具艺术性和抽象性，因为你不是专门制作看起来像动物的东西。你制作的东西可能仅仅因为它的重复性而美丽。所以我折了一个。哦，是的，我现在正在看其中的一些图片。看起来很棒。
Yeah, so I folded one. So it takes a long time to get the paper precreased. But once you do, like I folded this one, it was like a series of repeating overlapping squares. Can you precrease like 100 sheets at 100 sheets i mean like 20 sheets at once i tried yeah or like doing multiple like once you fold it in half doing the rest and essentially doubling it yeah you can do it to some extent but you end up building up an error because when the paper bends right like it bends around a radius that's increasing and it causes problems. And you do learn precision doing this.
是的，所以我折了一个。预折痕需要很长时间。但一旦你做到了，就像我折的这个，它是一系列重复的重叠正方形。你能一次预折 100 张纸吗？我是说一次 20 张？我试过，或者像做多个，一旦你对折，做剩下的，本质上是加倍。是的，你可以在一定程度上做到，但你会产生误差，因为当纸弯曲时，它会沿着半径增加的方向弯曲，这会引起问题。你确实在做这个的过程中学会了精确。
And I fold this overlapping square thing. And it was beautiful to look at initially. And then I like held it up to a light and actually see because some places only one layer. Some places are three or four layers. Some places two layers. And it produces like a grayscale picture. I don't know if you've ever seen like a lithograph. Is that what it's called?
我折了这个重叠的正方形东西。起初看起来很美。然后我把它举到灯光下，实际上能看到，因为有些地方只有一层。有些地方是三四层。有些地方两层。它产生了一种灰度图像。我不知道你有没有见过石版画之类的东西？是叫这个名字吗？
That sounds familiar. Lithopane. Something like that where they take wood and carve a negative of an image in it. And when you hold it up to light, you see the picture. I did that one year with a pumpkin. It took forever, but it was awesome. That's impressive. Yeah, I actually had a shape where at no point did I puncture all the way through the pumpkin.
听起来很耳熟。透光浮雕（Lithophane）。类似这样的东西，他们用木头雕刻出图像的负片。当你把它举到灯光下时，你就能看到图像。我有一年用南瓜做过这个。花了好长时间，但很棒。那令人印象深刻。是的，我实际上有一个形状，在任何地方都没有把南瓜戳穿。
But it was just like a different depth. So it came out pretty cool. Yeah. Yeah, so I did this with origami. And it was mathematical, right? T. So it came out pretty cool. Yeah. Yeah. So I did this with origami and it was mathematical, right? Tessellations are, are very,
但它只是深度不同。所以效果很酷。是的。是的，所以我用折纸做了这个，它是数学性的，对吧？T。所以效果很酷。是的。是的，所以我用折纸做了这个，它是数学性的，对吧？镶嵌是非常，
are very mathematical in nature. You can kind of apply that there. And even just in general, there's a lot of work, which I, a guy, I think his name is Robert Lang has done work on like crease patterns. So what happens when you fold the shape and then you unfold it and you look
本质上是非常数学化的。你可以应用在那里。即使在一般情况下，也有很多工作，我想，有一个人，我想他叫 Robert Lang，他在折痕图案方面做了很多工作。所以当你折叠形状然后展开它，观察
at the creases or whatever, and how do you describe that when like treatments of it? And can you find more optimal ways of folding or crease patterns and that kind of stuff it's just uh kind of the nerdy way of uh that thing you remember doing when so many years ago of like folding the paper and making the pirate hat that's pretty awesome okay on to the news so first news article html5 this is uh html5 is pretty much ubiquitous now i mean you'll hear the oh not supported in ie6 or something like that but people are giving up on that um and that might not even be true actually it's supported on a ton of browsers and it's got a bunch of really cool stuff in it there's some things that didn't quite make the spec and it's
折痕什么的，你如何描述它，以及它的处理方式？你能找到更优的折叠方式或折痕图案之类的东西吗？这只是那种书呆子式的方式，关于你记得多年前做的那种折纸，折纸做海盗帽，那真的很棒。好的，进入新闻。第一条新闻是 HTML5，HTML5 现在几乎无处不在。我的意思是，你会听到哦，IE6 不支持之类的，但人们正在放弃这一点，而且这甚至可能不是真的，实际上它在很多浏览器上都受支持，而且它里面有很多非常酷的东西。有些东西没有完全进入规范，而且它
still kind of evolving um one really cool thing that's pretty subtle is webrtc have you seen this i heard it but i don't know what it is yeah it's actually it's like a thing in javascript where on your website you can have a video chat like between or among the people like that are visiting your website and so the i think html5s is a link to this. There's a game, a 3D game of Pong, where the paddle is big enough where it has a face on the paddle, and you're actually playing your face against the other person's face. So it's like some kind of video conference where the ball's hitting you in the nose every time.
还在不断演变。一个非常酷且微妙的东西是 WebRTC。你见过这个吗？我听说过，但我不知道它是什么。是的，它实际上是 JavaScript 中的一个东西，在你的网站上，你可以进行视频聊天，在访问你网站的人之间。所以我想 HTML5 是一个指向这个的链接。有一个游戏，一个 3D 乒乓球游戏，球拍足够大，上面有一张脸，你实际上是在用你的脸对着另一个人的脸玩。所以这就像某种视频会议，球每次都打在你的鼻子上。
Yeah, it's pretty awesome. So yeah, HTML5 Rocks is a website that is sort of like an amalgamation of all the cool things you can do in html5 and all the updates to the standard so many of these things like webrtc you know when you hear html5 your first reaction is oh it's like new types of tags or like new dot HTML structure, right? And that's also true. But along with it comes a whole suite of JavaScript libraries that let you do just really cool stuff.
是的，这太棒了。所以，HTML5 Rocks 是一个网站，它汇集了你在 HTML5 中可以做的所有酷事以及标准的所有更新。很多这些东西，比如 WebRTC，你知道，当你听到 HTML5 时，你的第一反应是，哦，它就像新类型的标签或新的 HTML 结构，对吧？这也是真的。但随之而来的是一整套 JavaScript 库，让你做一些非常酷的事情。
And, yeah, there's a link to check it out. Yeah, so I keep meaning to have – I keep bookmarking all these cool sites and things I run across in other news articles and do that depth-first search or breadth-first search. Either way I go, I just end up with all the stuff that I need to read and learn. And yeah, this is on my list. Cool, cool.
而且，是的，有一个链接可以查看。是的，所以我一直想——我一直在收藏所有这些我遇到的酷网站和新闻文章，并进行深度优先搜索或广度优先搜索。无论我走哪条路，我最终都会得到我需要阅读和学习的所有东西。是的，这在我的列表上。酷，酷。
So the next thing is Nissan announced that by the year 2020, good vision, I guess, they're going to release a car that drives by itself. So Google is infamous or famous for doing this and working on their self-driving car and driving all around california and other places and now nissan has said that they are going to build like a test facility and they're going to have multiple affordable cars that drive themselves by 2020 and i mean this is something i get very excited about i remember for you know even growing up and hearing about this, they were going to embed pucks in the road and have cars that, you know, drove themselves.
下一件事是日产宣布到 2020 年，好愿景，我想，他们将发布一辆自动驾驶汽车。所以谷歌因为做这件事而出名，致力于他们的自动驾驶汽车，在加州和其他地方到处行驶，现在日产已经表示他们将建立一个测试设施，到 2020 年他们将拥有多款负担得起的自动驾驶汽车。我的意思是，这让我非常兴奋。我记得甚至在成长过程中听到过这个，他们要在路上嵌入冰球，让汽车自动驾驶。
And it just never happened. And you needed a lot of adoption. Like, everybody needed to switch over at once. This was a massive problem. And how would you ever do it? It always involved some ridiculous infrastructure. As you mentioned, like, put a puck every foot of all highways in the U.S. Yeah, it just seemed like
但这从未发生过。你需要大量的采用。就像，每个人都需要同时切换。这是一个巨大的问题。你该怎么做？它总是涉及一些荒谬的基础设施。正如你提到的，比如，在美国所有高速公路的每一英尺都放一个冰球。是的，这看起来
it would never take off and so i mean nissan announcing it google working on it like i mean these things give me hope that like maybe by the time my kids learn to drive they won't have to learn yeah that's right so it's pretty it's pretty amazing that i mean that's one of those things that's really going to sort of revolutionize the way we live i mean one of those things that's really going to sort of revolutionize the way we live i mean one of the things that's really done it for me is along the same lines is just a smartphone and the fact that you can just look anything up at any time and there's really no arguing over the other day we were arguing over stephen hawking whether i thought he died from parkinson's or he had parkinson's he's not dead yet but a lot of people thought he had lou garrick's
永远不会流行起来。所以我的意思是，日产宣布它，谷歌致力于它，我的意思是，这些事情给了我希望，也许等我的孩子们学会开车时，他们就不必学了。是的，没错。所以这非常令人惊奇，我的意思是，这是真正将彻底改变我们生活方式的事情之一。我的意思是，真正对我产生影响的事情之一，沿着同样的思路，就是智能手机，以及你可以随时随地查找任何东西的事实，真的没有争论的必要。前几天我们还在争论史蒂芬·霍金，我以为他死于帕金森症，或者他患有帕金森症，他还没死，但很多人认为他患有卢·格里克氏
disease and it turns out they were right but like we saw this immediately by looking it up on the phone and that's one of these things where it's like over let's say I guess 10 or 20 years you know something has come about which has like completely changed our lives and the way we the way we you know the way we work the way we think this is one of those things where a self driving car I mean we'll be able to play board games on the on the drive to work right okay if you might be willing to take a job that's an hour away because you don't have to drive yourself right i mean it's just like lives i mean taxi services will be totally different right yeah i think that's the big thing we don't anticipate i think the short-term vision is
病，结果他们是对的。但我们通过在手机上查找立即看到了这一点，这就是那种在，比如说 10 或 20 年内，出现了一些彻底改变我们生活、工作方式、思维方式的事情。这是一辆自动驾驶汽车，我的意思是，我们可以在上班路上玩棋盘游戏，对吧？好的，如果你愿意接受一个一小时车程的工作，因为你不必自己开车，对吧？我的意思是，这就像生活，我的意思是，出租车服务将完全不同，对吧？是的，我认为这是我们没有预料到的重大事情。我认为短期愿景是
like oh good when i get on the highway i can go to sleep right and okay actually in the short term probably not because most of the laws seem to say you have to have a driver who's licensed and ready to take over you know basically there at the driver seat and ready yeah but eventually you know that'll adapt but i mean i think the huge impacts will be like how much safer the roads are right like i don't know what happened the first time somebody gets sued but um until they're like i mean i think it there's drastic room for improvement and reducing the number of fatalities that happen on the road right and then additionally like you said like you know further like taxi service right like why would you need to own a car that you
哦，太好了，当我上高速公路时，我可以睡觉了，对吧？好吧，实际上在短期内可能不行，因为大多数法律似乎都说你必须有一名有执照且准备好接管的司机，你知道，基本上在驾驶座上准备好。是的，但最终，你知道，这会适应。但我的意思是，我认为巨大的影响将是道路变得多么安全，对吧？我不知道第一次有人被起诉会发生什么，但直到他们，我的意思是，我认为有巨大的改进空间，减少道路上发生的死亡人数，对吧？然后此外，就像你说的，进一步，比如出租车服务，对吧？为什么你需要拥有一辆你
don't use most of the time anymore if your car a car could just be there when you're ready to take it right take you where you want to go and it's like a taxi but no taxi driver and you kind of remove a lot of the stigmas or even like what if a hoa you know your homeowners association owned like three cars or whatever and that was part of your community right or i mean i don't even know but there's all these different things you could think about or even just driving you to the door and then going home right like it's your car but it takes you to work and then goes home yeah or even like a you know so like there's no parking problem anymore or some weird parking structures where your car is like the horse,
大部分时间都不使用的汽车呢？如果你的车可以在你准备好使用时就在那里，带你去你想去的地方，就像出租车一样，但没有出租车司机，你消除了很多污名，甚至像如果一个业主协会拥有三辆车什么的，那是你社区的一部分，对吧？或者我的意思是，我甚至不知道，但你可以想到所有这些不同的事情，甚至只是把你送到门口然后回家，对吧？它是你的车，但它带你去上班，然后回家。是的，甚至像，你知道，所以没有停车问题了，或者一些奇怪的停车结构，你的车就像马，
where you whistle and the horse comes and gets you up. It's like that. Yeah, or even for truck drivers, they could do something completely different while they're on the road. They could be surfing the internet or something. I don't know, but it's exciting. I'm glad to see more people getting involved in it, and I hope it'll work out.
你吹口哨，马就来接你。就像那样。是的，甚至对于卡车司机，他们可以在路上做完全不同的事情。他们可以上网什么的。我不知道，但这很令人兴奋。我很高兴看到更多的人参与其中，我希望它能成功。
It hasn't worked out that great for electric cars thus far. Like, I mean, I think we're getting better, but... Really? I think electric cars are doing really well, no? Yeah, but I think, like, in my opinion, I'm not a car enthusiast, but, like, I mean, Nissan produced the Leaf, which was a failure. Right, right. And it kind of seems like maybe they regretted it wasn't tesla's doing well yeah but like other car manufacturers haven't like gotten excited and also actually made legitimately good electric cars one interesting thing i was reading an article on quora and the the question in quora was people don't know quora is a social kind of networking
到目前为止，电动汽车的情况并不太好。我的意思是，我认为我们正在变得更好，但是……真的吗？我认为电动汽车做得很好，不是吗？是的，但我认为，在我看来，我不是汽车爱好者，但我的意思是，日产生产了 Leaf，这是一个失败。对，对。而且看起来他们可能后悔了，这不是特斯拉做得很好，是的，但其他汽车制造商还没有像那样兴奋，也没有真正制造出合法的优秀电动汽车。我正在阅读 Quora 上的一篇文章，Quora 上的问题是，人们不知道 Quora 是一种社交网络
type stack overflow for non-programming questions specifically that's a great way to explain it that's exactly what it is so someone asked the question what is the thing about your job that's like pretty common knowledge but to the rest of the world would blow their mind and the number one answer was that batteries and your storing energy are following moore's law which had never happened in the past it's just kind of over the past 20-30 years they've been following Moore's law. For people who don't know what Moore's law means is for the same price you can do twice as much every 18 months. So in other words for a long time processors were following Moore's law. So if you had say a 100 megahertz processor was $100
类型的 Stack Overflow，专门针对非编程问题。这是一种很好的解释方式，这正是它的本质。所以有人问了一个问题，你的工作中有什么是常识，但对世界其他地方来说会让他们大吃一惊的事情？排名第一的答案是，电池和你的储能正在遵循摩尔定律，这在过去从未发生过。在过去的 20-30 年里，它们一直遵循摩尔定律。对于不知道摩尔定律是什么意思的人来说，就是以同样的价格，你每 18 个月可以做两倍的事情。换句话说，长期以来处理器一直遵循摩尔定律。所以如果你有一个 100 兆赫的处理器是 100 美元，
18 months from now you could be pretty certain, a 100 megahertz processor was $100, 18 months from now, you could be pretty certain that a 200 megahertz processor would be the same amount, $100, whatever I said. So batteries are doing this now. So what that means is, you know, effectively, however much of the Tesla car is the battery, let's say that's half the cost. I don't know what it is. Let's just pretend. That is going to go down in half.
18 个月后你可以相当确定，100 兆赫的处理器是 100 美元，18 个月后，你可以相当确定 200 兆赫的处理器将是同样的金额，100 美元，无论我说什么。所以电池现在正在这样做。所以这意味着，你知道，实际上，特斯拉汽车中无论多少是电池，假设那是成本的一半。我不知道是多少。让我们假装一下。那将减少一半。
Like, you know, in in three years it's going to get cut into a fourth of what it is now or it'll go down by half and be twice as high capacity right yeah like yeah that's right or you would have twice the capacity at the same price yeah that's another way of looking at it yeah but uh but yeah i feel like the the it's still early but uh i regret not buying tesla stock Let's just put it that way. I'm pretty excited about it. Don't get me started on that. I don't know what it will be in the future, but it's done well so far.
就像，你知道，在三年内它将减少到现在的四分之一，或者它将减少一半，容量增加一倍，对吧？是的，就像，是的，没错，或者你以同样的价格拥有两倍的容量，是的，这是另一种看待它的方式。是的，但，是的，我觉得它还处于早期阶段，但我后悔没有买特斯拉股票。我们就这么说吧。我对此感到非常兴奋。别让我开始说那个。我不知道未来会怎样，但到目前为止它做得很好。
Yeah. I hope you'll say the same thing about a self-driving car startup, right? Yeah. It'll do something awesome or Google or Nissan or whoever. I mean, I think it's one of these things that it's good to have it happen. Right. Definitely. Anybody who's working on it, i'll be a cheerleader for
是的。我希望你对自动驾驶汽车初创公司也会这么说，对吧？是的。它会做一些很棒的事情，或者谷歌或日产或任何人。我的意思是，我认为这是好事发生的事情之一。对。绝对。任何致力于它的人，我都会成为他们的啦啦队长。
at some level yeah definitely i think it's great um so okay my article is a analysis of flight data set and this was pretty cool it was from mongo db's blog um for people who don't know mongo db is a no sql database i think we talked about it. We talked about this on our SQL episode. But they also have this blog where their interns kind of like write about cool things they do with MongoDB. And this blog in particular, I think is really interesting
在某种程度上，是的，绝对，我认为这很棒。嗯，所以好的，我的文章是对飞行数据集的分析，这非常酷，它来自 MongoDB 的博客。对于不知道 MongoDB 的人来说，它是一个 NoSQL 数据库，我想我们谈论过它。我们在我们的 SQL 剧集中谈论过这个。但他们也有这个博客，他们的实习生会写一些他们用 MongoDB 做的酷事。我认为这篇博客特别有趣，
because it's very simple, very easy to read. And, you know, a lot of people don't really know what data mining is. It's sort of this overused, very nebulous term. And, you know, this is sort of a pretty easy example where they got overused, very nebulous term. And you know this is
因为它非常简单，非常容易阅读。而且，你知道，很多人并不真正知道什么是数据挖掘。这是一种被过度使用、非常模糊的术语。而且，你知道，这是一个相当简单的例子，他们得到了被过度使用、非常模糊的术语。而且你知道这是
sort of a pretty easy example where they got access to... they didn't get access, I mean to open access to all the flight data from all the airplanes that have that have flown, commercial airplanes that have flown in America over I think past year or so. And it's just a series of cool things they do with that data. Like they explore the cascading effects of delays and things like that. I thought it was a really good read. Pretty simple, pretty fun. And it uses very simple MongoDB queries. It's not doing some kind of crazy, you know, logistic regression or something like that that you have to, you know, pour through a manual to understand. So yeah, give it a shot.
一个相当简单的例子，他们获得了访问权限……他们没有获得访问权限，我的意思是，开放访问所有飞机的飞行数据，那些在过去一年左右在美国飞行的商业飞机。这只是一系列他们用这些数据做的酷事。比如他们探索延误的级联效应之类的。我认为这是一篇很好的读物。非常简单，非常有趣。而且它使用非常简单的 MongoDB 查询。它没有做一些疯狂的，你知道，逻辑回归之类的东西，你必须，你知道，翻阅手册才能理解。所以是的，试一试。
Take a look at it and you could actually redo all of the experiments yourself. Yeah, this is really interesting looking right now. Yeah, yeah, totally. it kind of makes me want to have a lot more time yeah if they can figure out a way to data mine another hour in my day that would be pretty epic and that well okay i don't want to get sidetracked that's something interesting they have that what is that the quantified self movement which is not exactly what you're saying but similar which is like in order to find where you should improve you first have to track all this stuff right like you need like if you had more information about how you live your life you could do that like right now if you ask that question how would you even start you don't have any data right so there's
看一看，你实际上可以自己重做所有的实验。是的，这看起来真的很有趣。是的，是的，完全。这让我有点想有更多的时间。是的，如果他们能想出一种方法来挖掘我一天中的另一个小时，那将是非常史诗般的。好吧，我不想偏离轨道，这很有趣，他们有那个，那是什么，量化自我运动，这不完全是你说的，但类似，即为了找到你应该改进的地方，你首先必须跟踪所有这些东西，对吧？就像你需要，如果你有更多关于你如何生活的信息，你就可以做到。就像现在，如果你问那个问题，你甚至会怎么开始？你没有任何数据，所以有
like a group of people out there trying to like track basic metrics about them i'm probably butchering this but this is the high level view people out there trying to track basic metrics about them i'm probably butchering this but this is the high level view people out there trying to track basic metrics about themselves their weight their you know what their activity level was how they feel like any sort of you know varying set of parameters over time so they can analyze themselves and say you know how do i do better oh on days i drink coffee i feel better immediately but worse overall right you know so i should stop drinking coffee or things like that yeah totally yeah i mean if they can find out like certain things you do that cause you to lose a lot of time then yeah it's basically giving you free time if you can fix these things yep although maybe you'll spend you'll be more efficient and less happy and then you'll wish yeah that's right you shouldn't
一群人在那里试图跟踪关于他们的基本指标，我可能说错了，但这是高层视角，一群人在那里试图跟踪关于他们的基本指标，我可能说错了，但这是高层视角，一群人在那里试图跟踪关于他们自己的基本指标，他们的体重，你知道他们的活动水平，他们的感觉，任何种类的，你知道，随时间变化的参数集，这样他们就可以分析自己并说，你知道，我怎么做得更好？哦，在我喝咖啡的日子里，我感觉更好，但总体上更糟，对吧？你知道，所以我应该停止喝咖啡之类的事情。是的，完全。是的，我的意思是，如果他们能找出你做的某些导致你浪费大量时间的事情，那么是的，如果你能解决这些事情，这基本上是在给你空闲时间。是的，虽然也许你会花，你会更有效率但更不快乐，然后你会希望，是的，没错，你不应该
have surfed the internet ever so the last thing of news here is i uh recently i saw this book well i guess book online book ebook released as pdf all these different formats about bayesian statistics was released called probabilistic programming and bayesian methods for hackers i hope i messed that up too that sounds good and it uh is interesting because not only is a good, I've only read through about I think the first chapter so far. And so far it's really good. Mostly stuff I know about covering it really well.
曾经上网。所以新闻的最后一件事是，我最近看到了这本书，好吧，我想是书，在线书，电子书以 PDF 格式发布，所有这些不同的格式，关于贝叶斯统计，叫做《黑客的概率编程和贝叶斯方法》，我希望我也把这个搞砸了，听起来不错。而且它很有趣，因为不仅是一本好书，我到目前为止只读了大约第一章。到目前为止，它真的很好。大部分是我知道的东西，覆盖得非常好。
And they have this cool thing which I had seen several times since now where you kind of embed Python charting in the HTML or whatever. And so it actually will run different per run or whatever but actually show you like a graph that is generated from Python when you load the page. At least I think that's what it's doing. And the PDF, of course, has them just statically generated. But this is pretty cool.
而且他们有这个很酷的东西，我已经见过好几次了，现在你可以在 HTML 或其他东西中嵌入 Python 图表。所以它实际上会每次运行不同，或者什么，但当你加载页面时，实际上会向你展示一个由 Python 生成的图表。至少我认为它是这样做的。当然，PDF 只是静态生成的。但这很酷。
And I think later ones, I believe, have even some interactive things where you can change some stuff and see what happens and able to tell different parameters, effects. Like if you flip a coin 50 times, what about 500 times, you know, what happens? And just in general, Bayesian analysis, there we go, is left off. I mean, maybe Jason could talk more about this because I think he's been doing some stuff with it. But, you know, when I was in high school, we learned a little bit about statistics, but definitely nothing about Bayes.
而且我认为后面的，我相信，甚至有一些交互式的东西，你可以改变一些东西，看看会发生什么，能够告诉不同的参数，效果。比如如果你抛硬币 50 次，500 次呢，你知道，会发生什么？总的来说，贝叶斯分析，我们开始了，被遗漏了。我的意思是，也许 Jason 可以多谈谈这个，因为我想他一直在用它做一些事情。但是，你知道，当我在高中时，我们学了一点统计学，但绝对没有关于贝叶斯的东西。
And even in a statistics class, I think it was mentioned as like a side note. I didn't take in-depth statistics, which is a basic statistics class. And we did a lot of the conventional, what is it called? Stochastic statistics. Is that what it's called? Frequentist.
即使在统计学课上，我想它也被作为一个侧注提到。我没有修深入的统计学，这只是基础统计学课。我们做了很多传统的，它叫什么？随机统计学。是叫这个吗？频率派。
Frequent, okay, whatever that thing is. We did a lot of that, but we did almost none other than just cover Bayes' theorem, like what it was. So do you remember Bayes' theorem? I'm going to hold you to the chopping block. It like the probability of a given b is equal to and then yeah I could probably sit there and think about it for a minute but it's like probability of b probability of b
频率，好的，无论那是什么东西。我们做了很多那个，但除了涵盖贝叶斯定理，比如它是什么之外，我们几乎什么都没做。所以你还记得贝叶斯定理吗？我要让你上断头台。它就像给定 B 的 A 的概率等于，然后是的，我可能可以坐在那里想一分钟，但它就像 B 的概率，B 的概率
given a divided by something yep divided by probability of a yeah so just to recap yeah I got close I didn't learn something so Bayes rule is like kind of like the fundamental theorem behind sort of what's called inferencing which is you know the which is like the basis of prediction and machine learning right so the idea here is you know so the equation is as patrick mentioned is probability of a given b so imagine like probability that it rained today given that it rained yesterday is equal to the probability that it rained yesterday given the probability it rained today. So that's flipping those two around. Which was the hard part for me because it was like how do we improve things by flipping it? It was not intuitive to me.
给定 A 除以某物，是的，除以 A 的概率。是的，所以总结一下，是的，我接近了，我没有学到什么。所以贝叶斯规则就像某种被称为推理的基本定理，你知道，这是预测和机器学习的基础，对吧？所以这里的想法是，你知道，所以方程是，正如 Patrick 提到的，给定 B 的 A 的概率，所以想象一下，比如今天下雨的概率，给定昨天下了雨，等于昨天下了雨的概率，给定今天下雨的概率。所以这是把那两个颠倒过来。这对我来说是困难的部分，因为就像我们如何通过颠倒它来改进事情？这对我来说不直观。
So I'll get to that. Multiply by the probability of a over b and so um those two are pretty easy to figure out right so the idea here is in one you're going forwards like like a given b means what is it today given yesterday you're going forwards in time and so if you were to go another step forward, like, you know, tomorrow given today, that's really sort of, that's forecasting, right? But the probability of B given A is going backwards. So that's like saying, you know, using data that you've already seen, sort of, how can you, or, wait, yeah, I got this right. So yeah, probability of A given B is going
所以我稍后会讲到。乘以 A 除以 B 的概率，所以嗯，那两个很容易算出来，对吧？所以这里的想法是，在一个中，你向前走，比如给定 B 的 A 意味着给定昨天，今天是什么，你在时间上向前走，所以如果你要再向前走一步，比如，你知道，给定今天，明天是什么，那真的是某种，那是预测，对吧？但给定 A 的 B 的概率是向后走。所以这就像说，你知道，使用你已经看到的数据，某种程度上，你怎么能，或者，等等，是的，我弄对了。所以是的，给定 B 的 A 的概率是向后走，
backwards which means you know given data I've already seen how can I revise my new probability and so what it does is you know obviously if it rains one day it's probably more likely to rain the next day because because typically clouds hang over a place for more than 24 hours right depending on where you live but so you might start off with say what's called a prior distribution, which is I don't know. Like you could use, for example, say a beta distribution or a normal distribution, which says, look, I don't really know. I have a 50-50 chance of it raining and I don't really know if the fact that it rained
这意味着，你知道，给定我已经看到的数据，我怎么能修改我的新概率？所以它所做的是，你知道，显然如果有一天下雨，第二天更有可能下雨，因为因为通常云会在一个地方停留超过 24 小时，对吧？取决于你住在哪里，但所以你可能会从所谓的先验分布开始，也就是，我不知道。比如你可以使用，例如，说贝塔分布或正态分布，它说，看，我真的不知道。我有 50-50 的机会下雨，我真的不知道昨天下了雨这个事实
yesterday really matters. But then by observing several rainy days in sequence and applying bayes law you can come up with a new distribution which is skewed towards you know it raining several days at a time so it's kind of uh it's kind of a hard thing to grasp there's definitely a ton of awesome articles on bayes um but this uh i get the impression that this these guys also do a really good job i haven't read this one in particular but this uh i get the impression that this these guys also do a really good job i haven't read this one in particular okay yeah so i mean the thing for me too like at least in this introduction and i intend to go through more given more time but recently that's been in short supply um is that you know it is kind of jason was saying there i
是否真的重要。但通过观察连续的几个雨天并应用贝叶斯定律，你可以得出一个新的分布，它偏向于，你知道，连续几天降雨，所以这是一种，这是一种很难掌握的事情，肯定有大量关于贝叶斯的很棒的文章，但这个，我得到印象是这些人也做得很好，我没有读过这本特别的，但这个，我得到印象是这些人也做得很好，我没有读过这本特别的，好的，是的，所以我的意思是，对我来说，至少在这个介绍中，我打算在有更多时间的情况下通读更多，但最近这很短缺，是，你知道，这有点像 Jason 在那里说的，我
guess frequentist is the other way where you you know something happens and you count how often it happens or whatever versus kind of the base is actually a different but equally valid way of looking at the world it's just like two sides of a similar coin like they're both trying to describe and some have advantages and disadvantages but the fact that i only ever had one i guess i kind of felt like i was missing like there were certain things like i would get to and i wouldn't know how to like even think about them properly it was like like, oh, that's just because I only had the tool of applying the normal probability that you think about. It's 50% likelihood that if I flip this coin, it'll land on heads or whatever. And that's the only way I had to think about it.
猜频率派是另一种方式，你，你知道，某事发生了，你计算它发生的频率，或者什么，相对于贝叶斯实际上是一种不同但同样有效的看待世界的方式，它就像同一枚硬币的两面，它们都在试图描述，有些有优点和缺点，但事实上我只学过一个，我猜我有点觉得我错过了，就像有些事情，我会遇到，我不知道如何正确地思考它们，就像，哦，那只是因为我只有应用正态概率的工具来思考。如果我抛这枚硬币，它会正面朝上，或者什么，有 50% 的可能性。这就是我必须思考它的唯一方式。
So having another way to think about it, even if I don't remember the specific formulas or code it up, is helpful because sometimes it reveals nuances to a problem or ways of thinking about something that's been really helpful to me yeah there's many domains which are i guess for lack of a better word i'll say soft like for example poker with poker it's very stochastic i mean you don't know what card you're going to draw if you did then you just win right i mean well you wouldn't always win but you would play very well and make a lot of money right the reality is you don't know what card is coming next and so when you have play very well and make a lot of money, right? The reality is you don't know what card is coming next. And so when you have these very soft environments, what's more interesting than, say, a frequentist,
所以有另一种思考方式，即使我不记得具体的公式或编写代码，也是有帮助的，因为它有时会揭示问题的细微差别或思考某事的方式，这对我真的很有帮助。是的，有很多领域，我猜因为缺乏更好的词，我会说软，例如扑克，扑克非常随机，我的意思是，你不知道你会抽到什么牌，如果你知道，那你就赢了，对吧？我的意思是，好吧，你不会总是赢，但你会玩得很好，赚很多钱，对吧？现实是你不知道下一张牌是什么，所以当你玩得很好，赚很多钱，对吧？现实是你不知道下一张牌是什么。所以当你拥有这些非常软的环境时，什么比，比如说，频率派更有趣，
which will tell you, oh, you should probably bet more, you should probably raise, is sort of having a confidence. If your output is a distribution, then you can say, you know, the mode of this distribution, so in other words, like, what I think you should should play is, let's say, raise $15. But you have this huge uncertainty or, you know, I'm holding pocket aces. There's two more aces on the table. I have four of a kind aces. Now I have virtually no uncertainty.
它会告诉你，哦，你可能应该多下注，你可能应该加注，这是一种信心。如果你的输出是一个分布，那么你可以说，你知道，这个分布的众数，换句话说，就像，我认为你应该玩的是，比如说，加注 15 美元。但你有这种巨大的不确定性，或者，你知道，我拿着口袋对 A。桌上有两张更多的 A。我有四张 A。现在我几乎没有不确定性。
Right. So you can think of Bayesian as sort of living in this realm of distributions instead of numbers instead of like what's called point values and that lets you do a bunch of really interesting things yeah and you can do some it's been my impression
对。所以你可以把贝叶斯看作是生活在分布的领域，而不是数字，而不是所谓的点值，这让你做很多非常有趣的事情。是的，你可以做一些，我的印象是
it's like the stuff that you can do in one you can do in the other it's just how easy or hard it is so you can do confidence intervals and distributions you know and then I don't want to call it traditional because i don't think it's the right way but in the frequentist view right like you can't do that stuff but it was always like the most complicated thing we always did at the end of the semester yeah like you know it was very difficult to do but in bays it seems to come naturally like once you get everything set up which might be a little more tricky like all this other stuff comes for free essentially yeah i mean like the unit of your operations is a distribution it's like you're
这就像你可以在一个中做的事情，你可以在另一个中做，只是容易还是困难的问题，所以你可以做置信区间和分布，你知道，然后我不想称它为传统的，因为我不认为这是正确的方式，但在频率派的观点中，对吧？你不能做那些事情，但这总是像我们在学期末做的最复杂的事情，对吧？你知道，这很难做，但在贝叶斯中，它似乎自然而然地出现了，一旦你把一切都设置好，这可能有点棘手，就像所有这些其他东西基本上都是免费得到的。是的，我的意思是，你的操作单位是一个分布，就像你在
working with functions so in other words like for example if you add to normal distributions you get a normal distribution with the you know average or i think it's like the sum of means being the new mean or the average of means and the sum of the variances being the new variance but the point is like there's operations that you do on distributions rather than on numbers and that can be really hard like for example you can't take the product easily of two different distributions like if you have a logistic distribution and normal distribution and try and take the product there's just no closed form for that and so um in these examples like you have to do like monte carlo methods i don't know does this get to those uh i don't know mcmc and all of that mcmc yes opening the black box of mcmc oh
使用函数工作，换句话说，例如，如果你把两个正态分布相加，你会得到一个正态分布，你知道平均值，或者我认为它是平均值的总和作为新的平均值，或者平均值的平均值，方差的总和作为新的方差，但重点是，你对分布而不是数字进行操作，这可能非常困难，例如，你不能轻易地取两个不同分布的乘积，如果你有一个逻辑分布和正态分布，并试图取乘积，根本没有封闭形式，所以，嗯，在这些例子中，你必须做蒙特卡洛方法，我不知道这是否涉及那些，我不知道 MCMC 和所有这些，MCMC 是的，打开 MCMC 的黑匣子，哦
there you go yeah so so it's hard but mark of chain monte carlo yep i know i know what you said nice but then the output is just so awesome, right? I mean, think about that. Like now you have not only an answer, but a distribution over all the possible answers that could exist. So if you're writing, say, an AI to play Monopoly or something, you know, you don't want like you don't want something like what's the minimum amount of like how many houses should i buy so i don't get you know knocked out and have to mortgage right well that there's no clear answer because it depends on the dice right but if you use bayesian now you can come up with some kind of distribution that says like oh i have say a 90 confidence i'm not going to have to mortgage
给你，是的，所以这很难，但马尔可夫链蒙特卡洛，是的，我知道我知道你说了什么，不错，但输出太棒了，对吧？我的意思是，想想那个。就像现在你不仅有一个答案，而且有一个关于所有可能存在的答案的分布。所以如果你正在编写，比如说，一个 AI 来玩大富翁什么的，你知道，你不想，你不想像我应该买多少房子，这样我就不会被淘汰，不得不抵押，对吧？嗯，没有明确的答案，因为它取决于骰子，对吧？但如果你使用贝叶斯，现在你可以得出一个某种分布，说，哦，我有 90% 的信心我不会不得不抵押
and i can buy three houses in my monopoly game whatever right so um yeah it's pretty awesome i'm definitely gonna have to check this out and brush up on my bays all right with that in mind let's go to book of the show of the show show show my book of the show is i have also been looking into bays for a variety of reasons which is why you have so much to say about it one of them being that i need to get uh confidence intervals for some systems i've been working on and so i've been reading a book that is pretty heavy so i'll i'll give you a little bit of a disclaimer it's it's a heavy book i definitely recommend uh you know i think google books has it you can read the first like 50 pages without buying it right um on the flip side it's very thorough and you need no background so in other words if you're
而且我可以在我的大富翁游戏中买三栋房子，无论什么，对吧？所以，嗯，是的，这太棒了，我肯定得去看看这个，复习一下我的贝叶斯。好的，考虑到这一点，让我们进入本期节目的书。我的书是，我也一直在研究贝叶斯，原因有很多，这就是为什么你对它有这么多话要说，其中之一是我需要为我一直在研究的一些系统获得置信区间，所以我一直在读一本书，它相当沉重，所以我给你一个小免责声明，它是一本沉重的书，我绝对推荐，你知道，我想谷歌图书有它，你可以在不买的情况下读前 50 页，对吧？另一方面，它非常彻底，你不需要背景，换句话说，如果你
willing to slug it out um you won't have to like be a bayesian expert to understand this book but uh it is going to make you a bayesian expert so uh it's definitely a heavy read um computational bayesian statistics i think it's by uh let me look it up it's by a heavy read. Computational Bayesian statistics. I think it's by, let me look it up. It's by a guy in New Zealand, actually, who's pretty famous for this stuff. So this will cover what we've been talking about in exhaustive and dry detail, it sounds. Yeah, and I mean it. But that's good. It has one cool thing.
愿意努力读完，你不需要成为贝叶斯专家就能理解这本书，但它会让你成为贝叶斯专家，所以，它绝对是一本沉重的读物，计算贝叶斯统计，我想它是作者，让我查一下，它是作者，一本沉重的读物。计算贝叶斯统计。我想它是作者，让我查一下。它是新西兰的一个人，实际上，他因为这些东西而非常出名。所以这将以详尽且枯燥的细节涵盖我们一直在谈论的内容，听起来是这样。是的，我是认真的。但这很好。它有一件很酷的事情。
It has a bunch of pictures. It has pictures of distributions, things like that. And you can see sort of... So the author is William Ballstad. Okay, Understanding Computational Bayesian Statistics. Exactly. And it... Oh, yeah, it has understanding.
它里面有很多图片。有分布图之类的东西。你可以看到……作者是 William Ballstad。好的，《理解计算贝叶斯统计》。没错。而且它……哦，对了，它确实叫“理解”。
But I will post a link in the show notes that you guys can click on and check it out. I'm reading it now. It's an awesome read. It covers everything in great detail. You don't have to be a math genius or anything to figure it out or to follow along. And it's highly recommended. But there's this other one with puppies doing Bayesian data analysis.
但我会在节目说明里贴一个链接，你们可以点击查看。我正在读这本书。它写得太棒了。它非常详细地涵盖了所有内容。你不需要成为数学天才就能理解或跟上进度。强烈推荐。不过还有另一本关于小狗进行贝叶斯数据分析的书。
With puppies? It has puppies on the cover. Oh, man. Is it a distribution of puppies? There are three puppies. Oh, man. Okay a distribution of puppies there are three puppies oh man okay get the puppies okay never mind i was playing along at home uh so my book is one called going postal no it is not a serious book by terry pratchett so this is uh part of the disc world series which i haven't read a lot a lot of books but i've read
有小狗？封面上画着小狗。天哪。那是小狗的分布图吗？有三只小狗。天哪。好吧，小狗的分布图，有三只小狗，天哪，好吧，小狗的事儿先放一边，我刚才是在开玩笑。所以我的书叫《Going Postal》，不，这不是一本严肃的书，作者是特里·普拉切特。这是“碟形世界”系列的一部分，我没读过很多书，但我读过……
like i think three or four same here books from terry pratchett and there are a series set in this universe of craziness that's all i can describe it maybe i'm missing a lot of the jokes probably am it's not unusual but uh it's kind of just like silly adventures in this fantasy world right but the fantasy world makes fun of itself so yeah there's like trolls that are making fun of troll tropes or whatever right like you know there's a there's a hydra um used chariot salesman and you know hydras have like seven heads or whatever yeah yeah and his name is cut me on throat dibbler and if you can find a cheaper deal you can he'll cut one of his own heads off and grow 10 more and grow 10 more
大概三四本吧，我也是，特里·普拉切特的作品。它们设定在一个疯狂的宇宙中，我只能这样形容。也许我错过了很多笑话，很可能，这很正常。但它就像是在这个奇幻世界里的愚蠢冒险，对吧？但这个奇幻世界会自我调侃。所以，比如有巨魔在嘲笑巨魔的套路之类的，对吧？你知道，有一个九头蛇，呃，二手马车推销员，你知道九头蛇有七个头什么的，对吧，他的名字叫“割喉者迪布勒”，如果你能找到更便宜的交易，他就会割掉自己一个头，然后长出十个来，再长出十个。
yeah but he's like that's his threat you know you find a better deal and cut me on throat yeah so i mean there's some british amount of british humor in it so i equate a little bit to monty python style yeah um that's probably terribly unfair to someone i'm not sure who but uh this book is interesting and if you like a you know kind of a light-hearted read that's just fun when you get to the end it's not like you can tell somebody you had this deep you know story that was epic it's just kind of like a fun ride to read along and see what happens and the adventures of the people and the characters will recur in various stories even if the stories themselves aren't really sequential yeah definitely i mean in fact there's an order uh there's a reading order guide
是啊，这就是他的威胁，你知道，如果你找到更好的交易，就“割我的喉咙”。所以，里面有一些英式幽默，我把它比作蒙提·派森风格。这可能对某人很不公平，我不确定是谁，但这本书很有趣。如果你喜欢那种轻松的读物，读完之后感觉很有趣，而不是那种你可以告诉别人你读了一个史诗般深刻故事的书，它只是一段有趣的旅程，看看会发生什么。人们和角色的冒险会在不同的故事中反复出现，即使故事本身并不是真正连续的。是的，绝对是，事实上有一个阅读顺序指南。
online okay it's called the l space i should probably follow that i just read them randomly yeah it doesn't matter but if you read in a certain order you can catch all of the cameo appearances in the right order like you can see a cameo appearance of a character that and know what they've done already oh yeah that'd probably make more sense but and it's not like a normal order it's kind of like you have to read in kind of a wacky order so okay but yeah the books are amazing yeah that's it's definitely a light-hearted read so so is this one about like the postman or something yeah going postal yeah yeah so about this postal postal guy i don't like sharing too much about yeah we don't think about this because then i feel like yeah i definitely
在线的，好的，它叫“L空间”，我可能应该遵循那个指南，我只是随机读的。是的，没关系，但如果你按特定顺序阅读，你可以按正确的顺序捕捉到所有的客串角色，比如你可以看到一个角色的客串，并且知道他们已经做过什么。哦，是的，那可能更有意义。但这并不是一个正常的顺序，你得按一种古怪的顺序阅读。但书真的很棒。是的，这绝对是一本轻松的读物。所以这本书是关于邮差之类的吗？是的，《Going Postal》，是的，关于这个邮政人员。我不想透露太多，因为那样我觉得……
spoiled my computational vision so you guys know the ending in the ending uh you understand bayesian statistics spoiler well hopefully you do anyways yeah or at least you've seen a lot of cool pictures all right time for tool of the show tool of the show so this is a total cop out i'll be the first one to admit it my tool of the show show is two apps. My tool of the show are two apps. Anyways, my tools of the show are two apps that I wrote. One is NES Together and the other one is SNES Together. And as the name suggests, it's a way for you to play Nintendo and Super Nintendo games together with someone else on another Android device. So for example, I can take my phone, start up NES together,
剧透了我的计算视觉，所以你们知道结局了，在结局里，你们理解了贝叶斯统计。剧透，好吧，希望你们理解了，或者至少你们看到了很多很酷的图片。好了，节目工具时间到了。节目工具，这是一个完全的偷懒，我第一个承认。我的节目工具是两个应用程序。我的节目工具是两个应用程序。总之，我的节目工具是我写的两个应用程序。一个是 NES Together，另一个是 SNES Together。顾名思义，这是一种让你在另一台安卓设备上与他人一起玩任天堂和超级任天堂游戏的方法。所以，例如，我可以拿起我的手机，启动 NES Together，
pick an NES game like ice hockey or, I don't know, Contra or something, and then, you know, invite Patrick. He can join, and we'll both be playing Contra together. I see you post about this sometimes on Google+, and I'm very envious that you have so many friends to play old arcade games, old Nintendo games with. Yeah, I've been doing emulators for a long time, so I've kind of built an audience and a community of people
选一个 NES 游戏，比如《冰球》或者《魂斗罗》之类的，然后邀请帕特里克。他可以加入，我们俩就能一起玩《魂斗罗》了。我有时在 Google+ 上看到你发这个，我很羡慕你有这么多朋友可以一起玩老街机游戏和老任天堂游戏。是的，我玩模拟器很久了，所以我建立了一个受众群体和社区，
who are really into emulators, so there's always kind of somebody there. But you have your own hacks in the system, so you always win, right? Totally. Ah, nice. Yeah, I have this ice hockey hack, or it just sets the score to whatever I want. Every time I press volume up on the phone, I score a goal. How did that happen? Yeah, trick shot.
他们真的很喜欢模拟器，所以总有人在。但你在系统里有自己的外挂，所以你总是赢，对吧？当然。啊，不错。是的，我有这个《冰球》外挂，它可以把比分设成我想要的任何数字。每次我按手机上的音量加键，我就进一个球。那是怎么做到的？是的，特技射门。
But yeah, I think it's pretty fun. You know, a lot of these NES emulators are great. Like NESoid, the Android NES emulator is phenomenal. I'm not trying to compete with them. They have a great emulator. But none of them use the phone's internet. Like all of them require Wi-Fi. Oh.
但我觉得这很有趣。你知道，很多 NES 模拟器都很棒。比如 NESoid，安卓 NES 模拟器非常出色。我不是想和他们竞争。他们有一个很棒的模拟器。但他们都没有使用手机的网络。他们都需要 Wi-Fi。哦。
And so that's sort of the niche there, is that you can just be on a bus and start an NES game with your friends. So you can rack up your bill while you play. Exactly. Jason's getting a cut from the cell phone carrier. Yeah, Verizon totally has a deal worked out. So my tool to show is Joda, the Java
所以这就是利基市场，你可以在公交车上和朋友开始玩 NES 游戏。这样你玩的时候账单就会蹭蹭往上涨。没错。杰森从手机运营商那里拿分成。是的，Verizon 完全达成了一项协议。所以我的节目工具是 Joda，Java
time library. I actually don't know if they have one for C++, but I know of Java for sure. No, just Java. And so I'm terrible at calendar math and doing all things time related. Oh yeah, it's so hard. And handling things like leap years and daylight
时间库。我其实不知道他们有没有 C++ 版本，但我确定 Java 有。不，只有 Java。我非常不擅长日历数学和处理所有与时间相关的事情。哦，是的，太难了。处理闰年和夏令时之类的事情……
savings time. Oh yeah. It's really messy to begin with. And it's still messy when you use Joda, J-O-D-A. Didn't they change daylight savings time? Like something happened. It was like leap seconds or something? Oh, yes, like a few years ago, yeah. Yeah, something happened. They changed how it's done.
哦，是的。一开始就很乱。当你使用 Joda (J-O-D-A) 时，它依然很乱。他们不是改了夏令时吗？好像发生了什么事。是闰秒之类的吗？哦，是的，几年前，是的。是的，发生了什么事。他们改变了做法。
Yeah, right. So, I mean, like trying to keep up with that. Anyways, I don't know. Yeah, it's just that's kind of like a nightmare. Yeah, so this Joda library is a set of Java utility function things that allow you to manipulate times and do things like, what is today minus five days or minus one month, and set it and handle it appropriately for things like if I'm at March 1st
是的，没错。所以，试图跟上这些变化。总之，我不知道。是的，这简直是一场噩梦。是的，所以这个 Joda 库是一组 Java 工具函数，允许你操作时间，做一些事情，比如“今天减去五天”或“减去一个月”，并适当地处理它，比如如果我在 3 月 1 日
and I subtract a day and it's a leap year, it's different than if it's a non-leap year when I go to February, and handling all that stuff and doing it in a way which is at least semi-readable and approachable and i really have been doing a little bit more than normal with it and appreciate how much less time i have to sit there thinking about am i doing this correctly when i can just use the library yeah i mean this stuff is like a total disaster like time time so it's just it's just so hard and uh this library makes it so easy i mean i think that i don't know if you do this but i always do everything in i think what's called like usec or something or msec but it's
减去一天，如果是闰年，它和非闰年去往二月的情况是不同的。处理所有这些事情，并以一种至少半可读和易于理解的方式去做。我最近确实比平时用得更多，并且很感激我不用花那么多时间坐在那里思考“我这样做对吗”，因为我可以直接使用这个库。是的，这些东西简直是一场灾难，时间，时间，所以它太难了，这个库让它变得如此简单。我想，我不知道你是否这样做，但我总是用所谓的 usec 或 msec 之类的，但它
basically like microseconds dot current time epoch yeah yeah right so i do everything in that and at the last minute i use joda time to like convert that to something reasonable yeah so we have some stuff that like looks at data over the past and tries to accumulate like in the last seven days or last calendar month or last quarter and for a long time before you know that we undertook an effort to really make sure we were stringent about how we treat time it was like without fail every end of month or every quarter unit tests would just start failing you know and like it wasn't really that there was a problem it was normally that just the test was broken but it sometimes did reveal that we had legitimate problems where our data wasn't being
基本上就是微秒级当前时间纪元。是的，没错，所以我用那个做所有事情，在最后一刻我用 Joda Time 把它转换成合理的东西。是的，所以我们有一些东西会查看过去的数据，并尝试累积，比如过去七天、上个日历月或上个季度。在很长一段时间里，在我们努力确保我们对待时间的方式非常严格之前，每个月底或每个季度，单元测试总是会失败，你知道，这并不是真的有问题，通常只是测试坏了，但有时它确实揭示了我们有合法的问题，我们的数据没有被
calculated correctly or we'd miss a day here or there of course that's really really bad yeah totally totally yeah that's just totally really bad. Yeah, totally, totally. Yeah, that's just a total nightmare. I mean, you think about it, like, let's say you were, say, Groupon or something, and you tell someone, oh, you know, this offer is going to be here until midnight. Well, like, what does that even mean? I mean, like, if I'm in Florida and I take a plane to California, my midnight has just changed, right? I mean, it's like, like's like dealing with this stuff is such a
正确计算，或者我们漏掉了一天。当然，这真的很糟糕。是的，完全是。是的，这简直是一场噩梦。我的意思是，你想想，假设你是 Groupon 之类的公司，你告诉某人，哦，这个优惠将持续到午夜。那么，这到底意味着什么？我的意思是，如果我在佛罗里达，然后坐飞机去加利福尼亚，我的午夜刚刚改变了，对吧？我的意思是，处理这些事情简直是……
nightmare, and Joda definitely makes it a lot easier. Yep. So I think we're on to CUDA and OpenCL. Alright, so this is something that Patrick and I have done a lot of in our past life, and hopefully we remember a lot of it, but yeah, it's a pretty
噩梦，Joda 绝对让它变得容易多了。是的。所以我们进入 CUDA 和 OpenCL。好的，这是帕特里克和我在过去的生活中做过很多的事情，希望我们还记得很多，但它确实是一个非常
awesome, very powerful set of utilities. So I'll cover some of the history maybe. So firstly, I guess we should say that CUDA and OpenSALE both are ways of using the GPU, the graphics processing unit, in your computer to do something besides draw your 3D video game. So some of it may work with images or representations of images, but for the most part, you're doing general purpose, things which aren't related strictly to what the GPU was initially designed to do. Yeah, exactly, exactly.
棒、非常强大的工具集。所以我可能讲讲历史。首先，我想我们应该说 CUDA 和 OpenCL 都是使用 GPU（图形处理器）的方法，在你的电脑里做除了画 3D 游戏之外的事情。所以其中一些可能与图像或图像表示有关，但大部分情况下，你是在做通用目的的事情，这些事情与 GPU 最初设计的功能没有严格关系。是的，没错，没错。
So when GPUs came out, they really revolutionized gaming, right? I mean, I remember Dungeon Keeper 2 or Half-Life 1. Yes. Okay, yeah, so those were like right on the era where GPUs were coming out. Like Half-Life 1, you could either use a software renderer, which used your CPU, or it supported Glide, which was one of these early GPUs. And the idea is they're very specialized.
所以当 GPU 出现时，它们确实彻底改变了游戏，对吧？我的意思是，我记得《地下城守护者 2》或《半条命 1》。是的。好的，是的，那些正是 GPU 刚出来的时代。比如《半条命 1》，你要么使用软件渲染器，它使用你的 CPU，要么它支持 Glide，这是早期的 GPU 之一。它们的理念是它们非常专业。
They work with, there's two sort of elements in this pipeline. There's a vertex shader and there's a fragment shader. So again, these are meant for doing graphics and we'll get back to how they can do general stuff. But the vertex shader, so we're real quick on how computer graphics works. Everything is a triangle in computer graphics. Everything's just a bunch of triangles. The three
它们在工作时，这个流水线里有两个元素。一个是顶点着色器，一个是片段着色器。同样，这些是为了做图形设计的，我们会回到它们如何做通用计算。但顶点着色器，我们快速了解一下计算机图形学是如何工作的。在计算机图形学中，一切都是三角形。一切都只是一堆三角形。三角形的三个
points of the triangle are called vertices and so you have sort of an army of these vertices, just these triplets of vertices, like vertex A, B, and C make a triangle, D, E, and F make a triangle, and they all flow through the system and get transformed. Like one possible transformation is, you know, if you're playing like a first-person shooter and you turn your head 90 degrees, well, the way the graphics processing unit handles that is it rotates the whole world in the other direction 90 degrees.
点被称为顶点，所以你有一群这样的顶点，只是这些顶点的三元组，比如顶点 A、B 和 C 组成一个三角形，D、E 和 F 组成一个三角形，它们都流经系统并被转换。比如一种可能的转换是，如果你在玩第一人称射击游戏，你把头转了 90 度，那么图形处理器处理它的方式就是把整个世界向另一个方向旋转 90 度。
And so every vertex gets rotated in space to like counteract your rotation and make you feel like you're turning, right? And that rotation is a matrix operation. Right, that's right. So the vertex can be represented as a vector of three elements, you know, an X, Y, and Z component of the vertex. And then, right, any operation that transforms a vertex is a matrix operation.
所以每个顶点都在空间中旋转，以抵消你的旋转，让你感觉自己在转动，对吧？而那种旋转是一个矩阵运算。没错，就是这样。所以顶点可以表示为一个包含三个元素的向量，你知道，顶点的 X、Y 和 Z 分量。然后，没错，任何转换顶点的操作都是矩阵运算。
So like rotation, scaling, transformation, these kind of things. So there's a vertex shader. Once all the vertices have been transformed then they get crushed into the screen. So you can imagine sort of like all the vertices in your screen but they're all in 3D so they're all kind of these projections. Then they get crushed in a 2D and then what happens is something called a fragment shader starts at, looks at your three vertices and looks at every pixel that is within that triangle and then based on a bunch of different things figures out with the color of that pixel so for example a triangle might be red but there's a blue light shining on it and so the friend and it's facing that
比如旋转、缩放、变换，这些东西。所以有一个顶点着色器。一旦所有的顶点都被转换，它们就会被压入屏幕。所以你可以想象屏幕上的所有顶点，但它们都在 3D 中，所以它们都是这些投影。然后它们被压成 2D，接着发生的事情是，所谓的片段着色器开始工作，查看你的三个顶点，并查看该三角形内的每个像素，然后基于一堆不同的东西，算出该像素的颜色。例如，一个三角形可能是红色的，但有一束蓝光照在它上面，所以片段着色器会利用所有这些数据来算出，对于空间中的这个特定点，颜色应该是什么。所以这也是负责确定“哦，它在光的阴影面，还是面向正确方向”的部分吗？是的，还有，你知道，有些三角形可能是单面的，所以如果你面对的是三角形的背面，它就不会画出来，这被称为“背面剔除”之类的东西。所以这就像，哦，你在看一个立方体，但你只能在任何给定时间看到它的一部分，对吧？你可以站在能看到它全部的地方，对吧？所以立方体的背面，它不会画出来。好的。
blue light so the fragment shader will sort of use all this data to sort of figure out like for this particular point in space like what the color should be so is that also the part responsible for determining like oh it's on the shadow side of the light or facing the right yeah and also you know some triangles might be one-sided so if you're facing like the back of the triangle then it won't draw it this is called like back face culling and things like that so this is like oh you're looking at a cube but you can only see some portion of any given time exactly where you can stand where you see all of it right so the back part of the cube they won't draw okay
所以，呃，这可能是在顶点着色器中完成的，但在某个时刻，这些着色器中的一个负责说明哪些三角形存在，应该被画出来，哪些不应该。这真的很难，因为我记得好像在第一部《半条命》里，他们有一个游戏编辑器，他们会谈论这个，所以你需要小心放置东西来遮挡，这样算法就能决定“隔壁房间的东西不可见”，对吧？所以如果你画了一扇门和一堵墙，你留下了一个小缝隙，就像两个东西接触在一起，但有一个轻微的缝隙，算法可能会开始尝试画出
and so uh that's actually that might be done in the vertex shader but at some point like one of these shaders is responsible for saying which triangles exist like should be drawn and which shouldn't which is really hard because i remember i think it was in the first half life they had like a game editor and they would talk about this so like you needed to be careful to place things to block so that the algorithm could decide like the thing in the next room isn't visible right so like if you drew like a door and a wall and you left like a tiny gap like just two things kind of touching each other but there was a slight gap there the algorithm might start attempting to draw all the things
隔壁房间里的所有东西。是的，那会让它变得非常非常慢。是的，绝对是。所以，重点是人们发现这非常有用，而且速度非常快。你可以想到的一件事是，正如我提到的所有这些操作，让我们看看顶点着色器。你想把所有这些顶点旋转以适应你头部旋转的方式。但你想在每个顶点上做同样的旋转。我们在这里。你说“头”，也意味着“摄像机”，对吧？哦，不仅仅是模型的头在转，你是说摄像机在转。
in the next room yeah and that would make it go really really slow yeah definitely so um so the point is that the people found that this was really useful and it's very fast. So one thing that you can think about is like as I mentioned with all these operations, like let's look at the vertex shader. You want to take sort of all these vertices and rotate them to fit the way your head is rotating. But you want to do the same rotation on every vertex. So we're here. You're saying head and also meaning camera right oh not just like the model's head is turning but you're talking about like the camera is turning
没错，是的。所以你在玩一些 FPS 游戏，摄像机是你正在看的地方，对吧？你的眼睛在转，真正发生的是整个世界在转。所以它们在做同样的事情……等等，这就是我在现实生活中发生的事情，整个世界在你的头里转？真的吗？我很确定。这是那种“不可证明”的事情之一，对吧？比如，什么都不存在。
exactly yeah so yeah so you're playing some fps and you're in the the camera is sort of where you're looking at yeah yeah and your eyes are turning what's really happening the whole world is turning and so they're doing the same thing on wait that's what happens to me in real life the whole world turns into your head? Really? I'm pretty sure. This is one of those, like, unprovable things, right? Like, nothing exists.
比如，我现在在一个梦境世界里。你见过这个吗？比如，不可辩驳的论点？没有。我想维基百科上有一个关于这个的页面。总之，GPU 对在不同输入上做同样的事情进行了高度优化，你知道这实际上非常有用。我的意思是，看看机器学习。你可能会做线性回归，你想计算许多变量的巨大点积。所以你想取一堆变量
Like, I'm in a dream world right now. Have you seen this? Like, an undefeatable arguments? No. I think there's a Wikipedia page on this. Anyways, so the GPU is highly optimized for doing the same thing on a bunch of different input and you know that is actually really useful. I mean look at say machine learning. You might do say linear regression where you want to compute you know huge dot products of many variables. So you want to take a bunch of variables
并将它们加在一起，或者取一堆变量并将它们乘以某个东西。所以你可以在 GPU 上比在一个 CPU 上快得多地完成这个任务。所以人们开始意识到这一点，并开始想出各种酷炫的事情在 GPU 上做，而不是与图形相关的。但这涉及到一个非常非常痛苦的过程。所以他们必须做的是，你知道，把他们所有的输入数据转换成图像。所以找到某种方法把，你知道，他们的数学，比如，回到机器学习的事情。找到某种方法把矩阵的权重放入，你知道，图像上的纹理。然后你必须关闭所有的特效，因为他们不希望，你知道，光照在他们的权重矩阵上之类的。这根本说不通，对吧？
and add them together or take a bunch of variables and multiply them by something. So you could do this much, much faster on a GPU than on one CPU. So people started realizing this and started coming up with all sorts of cool things to do on the GPU that aren't graphics related. But this involved a really, really painful process. So what they had to do was, you know, convert all their input data to images. So find some way to put, you know, their math, their like, you know, going back to the machine learning thing. Find some way to put the weights of their matrix into, you know, a texture on an image. And then you have to turn off all the special effects because they don't want, you know, lights to be shining on their weight matrix or something like that. It just doesn't make sense, right?
或者，哦，当三角形离得越远，你的权重就越小，因为有雾，我的意思是这简直太疯狂了。所以你必须关闭所有这些，渲染一帧，然后片段着色器，你知道，它在屏幕上画所有的像素，那个片段着色器会做一些疯狂的事情，比如点积之类的，并把答案以像素的形式放在屏幕上。然后你必须读取屏幕并解释它。是的，因为 GPU 通常直接画到显示器上，对吧？它就是你插入显示器的东西，所以它有一点内存来保存显示器上的一切，对吧？没错。所以这真的很难，而且 CUDA 和 OpenCL 是……而且真的没人这么做。我的意思是，有人在做，比如疯狂的黑客，
Or, oh, as you as the triangle gets further out your weights get smaller because of fog i mean it's just like crazy so you have to turn off all these render a frame and then the fragment shader you know which is drawing all these pixels on the screen that fragment shader will be doing something crazy like a dot product or something and putting the answers on the screen in pixels then you have to read the screen and interpret that yeah because the gpu often draws directly to the monitor like it right it is the thing you plug the monitor into so it has a little bit of memory that holds what everything on the monitor should be right yep so this is really hard and uh so cuda and open are... And really nobody did this. I mean, there were people doing it, like crazy hacker people,
比如很棒的大神，以及非常专业的、一次性的定制东西。但后来只要库有变化或者出了新的图形 GPU，任何这些东西都会完全搞砸他们，因为他们做的事情是不被支持的。没错，他们做的事情是针对某一张特定显卡的，而且很多任务无论如何都与图形相关，因为只有那些知道如何编程的人才能做这些。我
like awesome guru people, and very specialized one-off custom things that they would do. But then any time there was a change in the library or a new graphics GPU came out, any of these things would completely just mess them up because they weren't doing something supported. Right, they were doing something that like specific to one particular card and also like many of the tasks where were graphics related anyways because those are only people who knew how to program them like i
在硕士论文中做过一件事，就是光从一个地方反弹，换句话说，光照进来，它照亮了整个房间。我之所以能做到这一点，是因为我有图形学的背景。没人能理解这堆疯狂的代码。你必须手动做一些事情，比如禁用雾。否则，你的答案就是错的。你不知道为什么。所以 CUDA 和 OpenCL 是一种方式，让我们不必成为图形程序员就能做
did one thing as part of my master's thesis which was like a bouncing light from one place so in other words like a light shines in and it radiates the whole room. And I was only able to do this because of the background in graphics. Nobody could understand this crazy mess of code. You have to manually do things like disable fog. Otherwise, your answers were wrong. You didn't know why. So Kudo and OpenCL are a way to sort of relieve us of having to be graphics programmers to do
基本的事情。这是一件好事，否则我永远也做不到。是的，完全是。所以你想讲讲？是的，我的意思是，这个想法是它在这个东西之上是一个抽象。所以现在确实，我想有足够多的人在做这个，所以他们做出了
basic things. Which is a good thing because otherwise I never would have been able to do it. Yeah, totally totally. So you want to cover? Yeah, so I mean, so the idea is it's an abstraction on top of this thing. So there now it is true that I guess there's enough people doing this where they make
特殊的让步，在这些硬件中，这些非常特定的硅片，是为了做图形处理而制造的，以允许这种通用处理。但最初它只是一种抽象。它就像我们有这个非常特定的，也许我们会在下一集讨论这个，但有点像你有一个通用 CPU，它可以做任何事情，然后你有这些非常专业的 CPU，它们没有很多操作，因为你要么必须模拟它们，要么必须添加本质上的 AND 和 OR 门来表示如何做那件事，因为处理器不习惯做那个，
special allowances in this hardware this these very specific pieces of silicon that are made to do this graphics processing to allow for this general purpose processing but initially it's just kind of an abstraction it's like we have this very specific and maybe we'll talk about this in the next episode but kind of like you have a general purpose cpu which can do anything then you have these very specialized CPUs which don't have a lot of operations because you either have to simulate them or have to add essentially AND and OR gates to represent how to do that thing because the processor just isn't used to doing it
因为它对阴影和光照不是必需的。但随着它们变得越来越复杂和强大，事实证明人们想在图形领域和普通领域做越来越疯狂的事情。所以人们意识到拥有这种抽象是有益的，你可以本质上把任何数组塞进图形处理器，然后 CUDA 和 OpenCL 主要就是一种编译普通 C 代码的方法，这些代码在矩阵上操作，把它们编译成一系列图形操作，让那些图形处理器去操作，
because it's not needed for shading and lighting. But as they got more and more sophisticated and more capable, it turned out that people wanted to do crazier and crazier things in both the graphics arena and the normal. and so people realized it was beneficial to have this abstraction where you could essentially shove any array into the graphics processor and then have what CUDA and OpenCL are mostly about is a kind of a way to compile normal C code that operates on a matrix, compile that into a series of graphics operations for those graphics processors to operate on,
然后是一种把数据取出来的方法，而不是通过“告诉我屏幕上现在应该有什么”这种方式。是的，没错。这样做的好处是，这些 GPU，不仅因为它们做非常特定的事情而非常快，而且它们往往有很多个，对吧？我的意思是，就在现在，我们开始进入人们电脑里有 8 个 CPU，或者 16 个，我甚至不知道，我都没跟上
and then a way to get the data back out without having to, a supported way as opposed to, tell me what should be on the screen right now. Yeah, right. And the benefit of that is that these GPUs, not only are they really fast because they do very specific things but there tends to be a lot of them like right i mean just now we're getting into like people having like eight cpus in our computer or maybe 16 i don't even know i don't even keep up
节奏。但我的意思是，你可以很容易地拥有，我不认为，当我们做的时候，它是 128、256、512，现在处理器有 1024 个。那些处理器只能做非常特定的事情，但你有很多个。是的，这可能是一个巨大的优势。是的，绝对是。我的意思是，这里的大权衡，你知道人们说“好吧，为什么不是所有东西都在 GPU 上？”，所以权衡是，正如帕特里克所暗示的，呃，所以只有，所以线程被分组为 warp。可能有 1024 个处理器或 1024 个线程，假设是处理器，但它们被分成 32 个一组。对于特定的 32 个线程块，它们在任何时候只能做一件事。所以换句话说，如果你有一些
with it a lot but i mean you can easily have like i don't think like when we were doing it it was like 128 256 512 now process like 10 24 processors those processors can only do very specific things but you have a lot of them yeah which could be a huge advantage yeah definitely i mean the big trade-off here you know people say well water isn't why isn't everything in a gpu right and so the trade-off is as product was alluding to um so there's only, so the threads are grouped into warps. There might be like 1024 processors or 1024 threads, let's say processors, but they're grouped in blocks of 32. And for a particular block of 32 threads they can only be doing one thing at any one time. So in other words if you have some
数据，在，你知道，第一个索引上你必须做一件事。在第二个索引上，你必须做第二件事，以此类推。就像它对每个索引都是特定的。这会花费你 32 倍的时间来做，因为，你知道，第一个处理器要处理第一个数据位。而所有其他的都要等待。所以在这个例子中，GPU 会非常慢，比慢得多。是的，就像如果你有一个单一的数字。就像如果你有，你知道，我有一个数字，
data and on you know the first index you have to do one know, the first index, you have to do one thing. On the second index, you have to do a second thing, so on and so forth. Like it's specific to each index. It's going to take you 32 times as long to do that because, you know, the first processors are going to work on the first, you know, bit of data. And all the other ones are going to wait. And so in this case, the GPU would be really slow, like much slower. Yeah, it's like if you had a single number. Like if you had, you know, I have one number,
我想做这几个数学运算，然后是一些分支，然后是一些其他数学，对吧？然后我想运行一些，比如我正在启动我的程序之类的。那组操作不适合 GPU，因为虽然有很多可以并行运行，但每一个并不一定像你的常规处理器那样快地完成一件事情，对吧？所以优势在于你可以同时做很多事情，而且它也带来了，因为这些图形东西没有
and I want to do these couple of math operations, then some branching, and then some other math, right? And then I want to run some, like I'm starting on my program or whatever. That set of operations isn't suitable to the GPU because although there's many of them that can run in parallel, each one isn't necessarily as fast as your as a regular processor at getting a single thing done right so the advantage is that you can do a lot of things at once and also it brings out they because this graphic stuff doesn't
很多需要做出的决定，它们在执行分支操作（比如 if 语句或 for 循环）时的性能通常开始变得有点棘手。所以一些 for 循环很好，因为你可以展开它们并运行它们。但像一个 for 循环，你正在……那么什么是展开？哦，好的。所以最初一个 for 循环是……这涉及到理解计算机是如何操作的。所以处理器并不真正理解什么是 for 循环。
have a lot of decisions that need to be made they're typically their performance at having branching operations like an if statement or a for loop like those kinds of things start to get a little hairy. So some for loops are good because you can unroll them and run them. But like a for loop where you're – So what's unrolling? Oh, okay. So initially a for loop is – and this gets into like understanding how computers operate. So the processor doesn't understand what a for loop is really.
所以它知道的是，好的，我要考虑一些条件语句。这个寄存器里的这个数字比那个寄存器里的那个数字大还是小？如果是，分支。如果不是，执行下一个语句。将程序计数器加一之类的。所以循环展开说，与其在到达 for 循环末尾时，跳回开头并再次执行这个条件，如果你的 for 循环是，例如，我有一个已知的 1000 个条目的数组，我想让它们是数字 1、数字 2、数字 3，你知道，本质上是 1 加上它们的索引，如果我
So what it knows is, okay, I'm going to consider some conditional statement. Is this number in this register more or less than this number in this other register? If it is, branch. If not, execute the next following statement. Increase the program counter by one or whatever. And so loop unrolling says instead of having to, when you get to the end of the for loop, jump back up to the beginning and execute this conditional again if your for loop is for instance i have a known 1000 entry array and i want them to be the number one the number two the number three you know one plus their index essentially if i
想让它发生，我已经提前知道我将不得不做这个，我说一百次或一千次，一百次。所以与其有一个循环说，你知道，检查，你知道，我当前的计数器是否小于一百。如果是，做这个，然后跳回去，对吧？这段代码一遍又一遍地运行。你可以一次性完成所有这些。所以，你知道，设置数组 0 为 1，设置数组 1 为 2，设置数组 2 为 3，设置数组 3 为 4。如果你按顺序写出所有这些，指令就更少了。如果你计算 CPU 实际占用的周期数，它少得多。它曾经更有益，
want that to happen i already know in advance i'm going to have to do this what i say a hundred times or a thousand times a hundred times. So instead of having a loop which says, you know, check if, you know, my current counter is less than a hundred. If so, do this, then jump back up, right? This code running over and over. You can just do all of that all at once. So, you know, set array zero to one, set array one to two, set array two to three, set array three to four. And if you listed all those in order, there's less instructions. If you count actually a number of cycles taken by the CPU, it's a lot less. It used to be much more beneficial,
但后来 CPU 变得越来越擅长理解这一点，例如，如果我在这个循环里一千次，下一次我来到它时，我很有可能已经要做下一件事了。所以它知道这一点。所以循环展开在这种情况下会说，哦，如果我要在 GPU 中做这组操作，实际上只是让它们成为设置指令，而不是这种分支，这在某种程度上会让 GPU 困惑，因为它期望所有的像素同时经历相同的操作，对吧？没错，如果你想知道，呃，你知道，基于你经历过多少次
but then CPUs got better and better at understanding that, for instance, if I'm in this loop a thousand times, there's a very high probability the next time I come to it, I'm going to do the next thing already. And so it knows that. So loop unrolling in this case would say, oh, if i'm going to do this set of operations in the gpu like actually just make them set instructions instead of this branching which confuses the gpu at some level because it's expecting all of the pixels to be going through the same operations at the same time right exactly and if you want to know uh you know based on how many times you've been through a
for 循环，你再次经历 for 循环的机会是多少，你可以阅读《理解计算贝叶斯统计》，他们正好讲了这类问题。你需要那个的原因是为了做流水线和所有这些东西。所以回到你的观点，GPU 没有很好的流水线，所以换句话说，CPU 会做各种疯狂的事情，比如我想是分支预测，它实际上会采取分支的两条路径，只要它不必向内存写入任何东西。好吧，是的，它会假设，它会在那个 for 循环中假设你要继续做下一个数组操作，并实际上开始做那个操作，对吧？但它还没弄清楚它是否应该这样做，对吧？然后一旦它弄清楚它应该这样做，它就继续保留那个答案。如果它弄清楚它
for loop what is the chance that you'll go through the for loop again, you can read understanding computational patient statistics where they go over exactly this kind of problem. And the reason you need that is to do pipelining and all this stuff. So to your point, the GPU does not have very good pipelining so in other words like a cpu will do all sorts of crazy things like i think branch prediction where it will actually take both paths of a branch as long as it doesn't have to write anything to memory well yeah what it'll assume is it'll assume in that for loop it'll assume you're going to go ahead and do the next array operation and actually start doing that operation right but it still hasn't figured out if it should or not right and then once it figures out it should then it just goes ahead and keeps that answer if it figures out it
“哎呀，我不应该那样做”，它有一种方法可以本质上刷新流水线，然后加载本来应该做的其他指令，对吧？比如加载那个，你知道，现在……但问题是你失去了所有那些你本应该做其他操作的时间。没错。是的。所以 GPU，因为它有这么多线程，而且因为它的设计直觉是所有线程同时做同样的事情，它没有任何这些。比如它没有分支预测。
oops i wasn't supposed to do that it has a way to essentially flush the pipeline right and then load the whatever the other instruction was supposed to do instead right like load that you know now but the problem is you lose all that uh time you should have been doing those other operations. Right. Yeah. So the GPU, because it has so many threads and because of the ways designed with this intuition that all the threads do the same thing at the same time, it doesn't have any of this. Like it doesn't have branch prediction.
它有很多像这样的东西，它没有。所以回到帕特里克的话，如果你有一个分支，假设你有一个分支，比如如果我正在，你知道，操作这个数据数组的第一个，那么做一些特别的事情，当你在一个线程上做那个特别的事情时，其他 31 个线程只是在等你完成，呃，所以这很糟糕。所以，呃，但你知道，事实证明许多非常 CPU 密集型的程序并不真的需要很多分支。不，比如，你知道，视频转码和我们正在考虑的事情，比如所有的，像摄影，我总是想到摄影之类的东西，因为这是我稍微了解一点的东西，但比如如果你想应用一个模糊，
There's a lot of things like this that it does not have. And so to Patrick's point, if you have a branch, let's say you have a branch, like if I am, you know, operating on the first of this array of data then do something special while you're doing that special thing on one thread the other 31 threads are just waiting for you to finish and uh and so that's bad so uh so but you know it turns out many very cpu intense programs don't really need a lot of branching no so like you know video transcoding and things we're thinking about like all the like photography i always think about like photography stuff because it's something i understand a little bit about but like if you want to apply a blur
对，对，你有一张图像，你的输入图像，你有一张输出图像，你有一个你要用来做模糊的东西，这是一个矩阵，你只需要添加每个像素，把那个矩阵应用到输入图像上。是的，那里真的没有很多分支要做，你只需要知道在每个像素上需要做什么，直接去做，你可以并行地做它们，对吧？没错，对吧，就像对每个像素做这件事，而不是对这张图像遍历它并做这件事。是的，完全是，完全是。呃，你听到很多关于，你知道，GPU 编程的疯狂事情，比如“哦，我有 60 倍的加速，我有 200 倍的加速”，对吧？大多数时候，那些是
right right you take you have one image your input image and you have your output image and you have your thing you're going to to use to do the blurring which is a matrix you just need to add every pixel apply that matrix to the input image yeah there's isn't really a lot of branching to be done there you just know what needs to be done at every at every pixel just go ahead and do it and you can do them all in parallel right exactly right like just for every pixel do this thing as opposed to for this image go through it and do this thing yeah exactly exactly um you hear a lot of crazy things about uh you know gpu programming like oh i have a 60x speed up i have a 200x speed up right most of the time those were things that
编程得很糟糕的东西，你知道，好吧，我的意思是，我喜欢的术语是“尴尬地并行”或者其他什么，尴尬地适合 GPU。如果你给 GPU 的东西几乎和它被建造出来要做的事情一模一样，那它就很棒。是的，但这是一个非常陡峭的下降，如果你超出了它的非常……哦，现在我在用低音说话，如果你有这个，你知道，这个东西在任何接近那个东西的事情上都非常好，对吧？它也会得到一个巨大的加速，但即使你只是在任何一个方向上稍微移动一点，你得到的性能就开始急剧下降，对吧？而且有很多事情，你知道，带有 SIMD 的 CPU 和这些东西，可以做得相当好，但有了这个，GPU 是
were programmed badly you know well i mean things that are what i the term i like is embarrassingly parallel or whatever embarrassingly suited to gpu like if you give the gpu something that's almost exactly like what it was built to do it's awesome yeah but it's a very sharp descent like if you get outside of its very oh now i'm talking in like bass if you have this like you know this thing is really good at anything near that thing right it will also get a really huge speed up but even if you just move a little outside in any one of the directions you get like the performance starts to drop drastically right and there's a lot of things that you know cpus with simd and these kind of things uh can do can do pretty well but but with that the gpus are
相当棒的，加速几乎总是值得的，呃，为了额外的，你知道，工程努力，如果它是，是的，如果它是矩阵类型的东西，并且你正在使用图像或视频或任何这些东西，是的，它会很棒。是的，完全是，完全是。在大多数情况下。所以有人会抵消这一点。
pretty awesome the speed up is almost always worth it um to for the extra you know engineering effort if it's yeah if it's a matrix-type thing and you're using images or video or any of these things, yeah, it's going to be awesome. Yeah, totally, totally. For the most part. So somebody will counteract this.
但你确实必须付出代价，因为你必须从系统 RAM 移动到 GPU 的 RAM。没错。而且 GPU RAM 真的很快，这很好，但你必须付出代价在总线（PCI Express 或其他什么）上来回移动。
But you do have to pay a penalty because you have to move from system RAM to the GPU's RAM. Right. And GPU RAM is really fast, which is great, but you have to pay that penalty to move back and forth over whatever the bus, PCI Express or whatever.
所以这是一个不可忽略的时间量。是的，这就是你的观点，你必须做大量的流水线。比如你必须说，好的，GPU，我想让你在图像的这一部分做这个，但然后，比如当你做那个的时候，我要给你发送下一张图像。只要你能某种程度上，
And so that is a non-negligible amount of time. Yeah, and that's to your point, you have to do a lot of pipelining. Like you have to say, okay, GPU, I want you to do this on this part of the image, but then like while you're doing that, I'm gonna be sending you the next image. And as long as you can sort of,
这样就像 GPU 在工作，总线在同时发送东西。你不是只是串行地做事情。所以像任何并行程序一样，更不用说那种如此疯狂、高度并行的程序，调试简直是疯了。哦，是的。调试有点。你没有很多奇怪的，至少如果你坚持大多数人做的那种最基本的东西，你不会以很多竞争条件结束，因为你不应该在大多数这种 GPU 编程中做那种事情。但即便如此，你，这很难，因为如果你遍历程序的循环，那
so that way it's sort of like the GPU is working and the bus is sending things at the same time. You're not just doing things serially. So like any parallel program, much less one that's so crazily, highly parallel, debugging is crazy. Oh, yeah. Debugging is kind of. You don't have a lot of the weird, like, at least if you stick to the most basic kind of stuff that most people do, you don't end up with a lot of race conditions because you shouldn't be doing that kind of stuff um in most of this uh gpu programming but even still like you're it's hard because if you go through a loop of the program what does that
到底意味着什么？比如你在一个处理器的一张图像的一个像素里，你在看某样东西，但交互可能比那个稍微高一点。你需要某种方法在你的 CPU 上模拟它，因为 GPU 没有像 CPU 那样的断点能力。所以是的，它正在变好，但它确实很难。是的，是的。我的意思是，当我们做的时候，
really mean like you're in one pixel of one image and one processor and you're looking at something but the interaction is probably something slightly higher level than that. And you need some way to simulate it on your CPU because GPUs don't have the same kind of breakpointing ability as CPUs do. So yeah, it's getting better, but it is definitely hard. Yeah, yeah. I mean, when we were doing it,
我的意思是，你就像是在一张图像的一个像素和一个处理器上观察某样东西，但这种交互的层级可能要稍微高一些。你需要某种方法在 CPU 上模拟它，因为 GPU 不具备 CPU 那样的断点调试能力。所以，是的，情况正在好转，但这确实很难。没错，没错。我的意思是，当我们这样做的时候，
it was kind of a nightmare. I think it has come a long way though. It's really gotten a lot better there. One interesting thing is for data on the GPU, there's three different types of arrays that you can allocate on the GPU. There's a read-only, so the idea is you're allowed to write to this array once and that's it. You can only read from it. And only the GPU can read from it, not the CPU. And so if you go there, it's going to put it in some structure which, you know, the bus isn't allowed to talk to this structure anymore.
这简直是一场噩梦。不过我认为它已经取得了长足的进步，现在真的好多了。一个有趣的点是关于GPU上的数据，你可以在GPU上分配三种不同类型的数组。有一种是只读的，意思是你只能向这个数组写入一次，仅此而已。你只能从中读取数据。而且只有GPU可以读取它，CPU不行。所以如果你这样做，它会把它放在某种结构中，你知道，总线是不允许再访问这个结构的。
It sort of locks it off, but it puts it in a place that's very easily accessible by the GPU. Also, it knows that this data is never going to be written to by the CPU, so it can do some optimizations there. Like it can do some operations like in a pipeline, knowing that it's not dependent. Yeah, there's no data dependency. There's write only.
它相当于把它锁住了，但把它放在了一个GPU非常容易访问的地方。此外，它知道CPU永远不会向这些数据写入，所以它可以进行一些优化。比如它可以在流水线中进行一些操作，因为它知道没有依赖关系。是的，没有数据依赖。还有只写。
So for example, like all of your input data, you don't want to read that back from the GPU. I mean, you have it already on the CPU and it's completely in its pure form, right? So all your input data, you mark it as write only. And again, the GPU knows that you're never gonna have to pull that back. So you can do some crazy things,
所以举个例子，比如你所有的输入数据，你不想从GPU读回它们。我的意思是，你已经在CPU上拥有了它们，而且它们处于最纯粹的形式，对吧？所以你把你所有的输入数据标记为只写。同样，GPU知道你永远不需要把它们拉回来。所以你可以做一些疯狂的事情，
put it in some volatile memory and things like that. Or read-write. And so read-write is the slowest. The GPU expects at any moment, you're gonna read that data. And so it has to sort of keep it in a state that's stable. But sometimes you need that. And you bring up one of the things which is confusing at first is whose perspective are you talking from? So if it's read-only, is it from the CPU or GPU?
把它们放在某种易失性内存中之类的。或者读写。读写是最慢的。GPU随时都在预期你会读取这些数据。所以它必须保持在一个稳定的状态。但有时你需要这样做。你提到了一个起初很令人困惑的事情，那就是你是在从谁的角度说话？所以如果是只读，那是从CPU还是GPU的角度？
Write-only, and you just have to be careful to balance that in your head. Like when you say something, whose perspective are you talking from? Yeah, that's a really good point. Yeah. I mean, so just to recap, read-only means, you know know you send it to the GPU and you never expect to get it back so the GPU can read it and you can't so it's GPU read-only and then GPU write-only is something that the CPU only will read not the GPU write GPU write so write-only is where the CPU writes it,
只写，你必须小心在脑海中平衡这一点。比如当你说话时，你是从谁的角度出发的？是的，这是一个很好的观点。我的意思是，总结一下，只读意味着你把它发送给GPU，并且从不指望把它拿回来，所以GPU可以读取它而你不能，所以它是GPU只读；然后GPU只写是指CPU只会读取而不会写入，GPU写入，所以只写是指CPU写入，
but the CPU will never read it from the GPU. I think that's what you just said for the other one too. It's okay. There are opposites. There's two, one for each of the opposite sides. It's okay. My bad. We got it. We got it.
但CPU永远不会从GPU读取它。我想你刚才对另一个也是这么说的。没关系。它们是相反的。有两个，每个相反的一侧各一个。没关系。我的错。我们明白了。我们明白了。
Yeah, I think we've beaten this one. You should look it up. So the first one, first library we talked about CUDA is something written by NVIDIA, specifically for NVIDIA GPUs. Right. So that has some advantages. They know certain things will be present or that they can rely on our architecture. And they're a company that is very highly invested in keeping you locked into their platform.
是的，我想我们已经把这个问题讲透了。你应该去查一下。所以第一个，我们谈到的第一个库CUDA是由NVIDIA编写的，专门用于NVIDIA的GPU。对吧。所以这有一些优势。他们知道某些东西会存在，或者他们可以依赖我们的架构。而且他们是一家非常致力于让你锁定在他们平台上的公司。
But in turn, they kind of give you a lot of niceties. Yeah. A good analogy would be directx yeah like directx it's windows only and uh so it's like the os and the gpu can sort of have an agreement which open gl isn't can't do that because it's supported on so many different devices yeah you can have it linked in with your programming language of choice but then you have specific components, parts, files which are flagged essentially as CUDA parts which are
但反过来，他们也给了你很多便利。是的。一个很好的类比是DirectX，是的，就像DirectX一样，它只支持Windows，所以操作系统和GPU可以达成某种协议，而OpenGL做不到，因为它支持太多的不同设备。是的，你可以把它与你选择的编程语言链接起来，但你会有特定的组件、部分、文件，本质上被标记为CUDA部分，它们是
C programs but written in a restricted set so you can't have function pointers, you can't there's a couple of restrictions I don't think you can have global variables or maybe you can over time they tend to become more and more relaxed they figure out how to do more and more things.
C程序，但写在一个受限的集合中，所以你不能有函数指针，你不能，还有一些限制，我不认为你可以有全局变量，或者也许你可以，随着时间的推移，它们往往变得越来越宽松，他们想出了如何做越来越多的事情。
But you might get a penalty for doing them. So there's a little bit of, and all of these we'll talk about. There's a, more so than normal programming, there's a strong responsibility on the programmer to understand what they're doing and whether it'll be expensive or not. Right. Yeah, like, one thing that you might not expect, integer operations are really expensive. And it's because everything in graphics is floating point like where points of a triangle are in space and things like that have always been done in floating point and so there's i mean now this might be different but when we were doing it
但你可能会因为这样做而受到惩罚。所以有一点，所有这些我们都会谈到。比起正常的编程，程序员有更强的责任去理解他们在做什么，以及它是否昂贵。对吧。是的，比如，你可能没预料到的一点是，整数运算非常昂贵。这是因为图形中的一切都是浮点数，比如三角形的顶点在空间中的位置等等，一直都是用浮点数完成的，所以我的意思是，现在这可能不同了，但当我们做的时候
there wasn't really like an integer in operations and hardware and so that made it actually is much faster for us to do floating point division and if there's a little bit of loss. Yeah, it's okay and Like I said Nvidia provides some special libraries on top of just CUDA itself that are really good at some of the things a Lot of people want to do like fast Fourier transform Linear algebra stuff so the blast stuff They provide their own versions of this where instead of handling all these things we've been talking about, if you know I just want to do a Fourier transform on this data, you just call it and it transfers the data over,
硬件中并没有真正的整数运算，所以实际上对我们来说进行浮点除法要快得多，如果有一点损失的话。是的，没关系。而且就像我说的，NVIDIA在CUDA本身之上提供了一些特殊的库，它们在很多人想做的事情上非常出色，比如快速傅里叶变换、线性代数之类的。BLAS之类的东西，他们提供了自己的版本，而不是处理我们一直在谈论的所有这些事情，如果你知道我只是想对这些数据做傅里叶变换，你只需调用它，它就会传输数据，
performs the operation, and brings it back. And when you get done, you just have it there. Yep, so for people who don't know what fast Fourier transform is, I'll give my two-second or five-second explanation. Okay, go. Okay, so if you have a series of data, let's say it's a time series or it could be spatial series, you know, like an array, you know, like a 1D image or something like that, right?
执行操作，然后带回来。当你完成后，你就在那里得到了结果。是的，所以对于那些不知道什么是快速傅里叶变换的人，我会给出一个两秒或五秒的解释。好的，开始。好的，如果你有一系列数据，假设它是一个时间序列，或者它可以是空间序列，你知道，就像一个数组，你知道，就像一个一维图像之类的，对吧？
What a fast Fourier transform tries to do is turn that image into a frequency space. And a really simple way of explaining it is, you know, it tries to find a bunch of coefficients such that you can add a bunch of cosine waves together and recreate your original signal. You described Fourier transform. You've got zero seconds left to describe the fast part. I have no idea. Do you know fast? Yeah, so I think it's basically Fourier transform is a mathematical notion for continuous signals, for the most part. But yet in the computer world, a lot of times we're dealing with discrete signals. So you want to convert your wave to MP3, or at least analyze your wave or whatever.
快速傅里叶变换试图做的是将该图像转换为频率空间。解释它的一个非常简单的方法是，你知道，它试图找到一堆系数，这样你就可以把一堆余弦波加在一起并重建你的原始信号。你描述的是傅里叶变换。你还剩零秒来描述“快速”部分。我不知道。你知道快速吗？是的，所以我认为它基本上傅里叶变换在很大程度上是针对连续信号的数学概念。但在计算机世界中，很多时候我们处理的是离散信号。所以你想把你的波形转换成MP3，或者至少分析你的波形之类的。
But you only have sample points so far apart, and the signal ends at some point. You have an end of your file. So the Fourier transform will turn your discrete signal basically into sort of a continuous signal by storing all of these coefficients of a bunch of cosines that you can then add together at any point. So fast Fourier just exploits some notions that because it's discrete, because it ends, and there's some symmetries, how do you do it faster? And I don't know the specifics of it. The math always escapes me. I try about once every month to read some article that's supposed to explain it to me.
但你只有相隔很远的采样点，而且信号在某一点结束。你的文件有结尾。所以傅里叶变换基本上会通过存储一堆余弦的系数，将你的离散信号变成某种连续信号，然后你可以在任何点将它们加在一起。所以快速傅里叶变换只是利用了一些概念，因为它是离散的，因为它有结尾，并且有一些对称性，你怎么能做得更快？我不知道它的具体细节。数学总是让我头疼。我大约每个月尝试读一次应该向我解释它的文章。
And I still miss it. But it has to do with symmetries and optimizations because of, you know, what you're working with. Gotcha. So, yeah, if you ever wondered how MP3 works, I'll give it to you really quickly. Oh, dear. I mean, it's really like a discrete cosine transform, so it's a little different. But it's like an exact FFT. But just imagine, you know, instead of storing.
但我还是没弄懂。但它与对称性和优化有关，因为你知道，你正在处理什么。明白了。所以，是的，如果你曾经想过MP3是如何工作的，我会很快告诉你。哦，亲爱的。我的意思是，它真的很像离散余弦变换，所以它有点不同。但它就像一个精确的FFT。但试想一下，你知道，与其存储。
So, you know, music comes in like a wave. Everyone's seen like this. What is that machine where it like lets you show different pitches and it shows you the wavelength of the pitch and everything? It's like a... A tuning fork? No, no, it's like a machine and it has graphs and it also has a pitch. And you can like turn a knob and the graph will like...
所以，你知道，音乐以波的形式进入。每个人都见过像这样的东西。那个让你展示不同音高并显示音高波长和所有东西的机器叫什么？它就像一个……音叉？不，不，它就像一台机器，它有图表，它也有音高。你可以转动旋钮，图表就会……
The wavelength will shrink in the graph and the graph will like the wavelength will shrink in the graph and the picture go okay i don't know oh we had one that uh okay anyways so uh so music comes in waves oh i do okay oh you know what i'm talking about now yeah you don't know the name either okay oscilloscope oscilloscope that's exactly what i was thinking okay so everyone's seen an oscilloscope which has sort of those waves right and and it's how that's exactly how I was thinking of. Okay so everyone's seen an oscilloscope which has sort of those waves right and and it's how that's connected to music. So you can store these waves and the way an mp3 does this is if you have let's say like a cosine you can find a cosine that kind of fits your wave and you can you know pick a certain amplitude which is how high the cosine goes and a certain frequency which is sort of how narrow each of those up
波长会在图表中缩小，波长会在图表中缩小，画面会……好吧，我不知道。哦，我们有一个……好吧，无论如何，所以音乐以波的形式进入。哦，我知道了。哦，你知道我在说什么了。是的，你也不知道名字。好吧，示波器。示波器，那正是我在想的。好的，所以每个人都见过示波器，它有那种波，对吧，这就是它与音乐的联系。所以你可以存储这些波，MP3这样做的方式是，如果你有，比如说一个余弦波，你可以找到一个适合你波形的余弦波，你可以，你知道，选择一个特定的振幅，也就是余弦波上升的高度，以及一个特定的频率，也就是那些上升的每一个有多窄
down hills are and so you can find you know a frequency and amplitude such that it tries to approximate you know like kanye west's song or something like that right and you you won't get all of it of course with one cosine you'll get a little bit of it so then you take that part out of kanye's song and now it sounds a little different, but hopefully you find another cosine wave that can now match that new song. And then you basically keep doing this until you end up with nothing. And you have like all these cosine waves
下降的山丘，所以你可以找到，你知道，一个频率和振幅，使得它试图近似，你知道，比如坎耶·韦斯特的歌之类的，对吧，你当然不能用一个余弦波得到全部，你会得到一点点，所以你把那部分从坎耶的歌中拿出来，现在听起来有点不同，但希望你能找到另一个余弦波，现在可以匹配那首新歌。然后你基本上一直这样做，直到你什么都不剩。你就有所有这些余弦波
and when you add them together, you get Kanye West song. Yeah, so essentially relies on the fact your ear can't hear all of the little differences. Right. So if something's changing really, really fast, it's probably unimportant. It's probably just quote unquote noise or whatever that could be filtered away. Yeah.
当你把它们加在一起时，你就得到了坎耶·韦斯特的歌。是的，所以本质上依赖于你的耳朵听不到所有细微差别的事实。对吧。所以如果有什么东西变化得非常非常快，它可能是不重要的。它可能只是所谓的“噪声”或者其他可以被过滤掉的东西。是的。
And the same thing is true for images. JPEG is the same thing. It tries to say in this area of a white wall, there's almost no difference between two pixels. So if I just approximate it, you won't lose very much information. It tries to very carefully pick what information to store as opposed to storing everything. Yep, exactly. And so get back to NVIDIA. So NVIDIA has a
图像也是如此。JPEG也是一样。它试图说在白墙的这个区域，两个像素之间几乎没有区别。所以如果我只是近似它，你不会丢失太多信息。它试图非常小心地选择存储什么信息，而不是存储所有东西。是的，完全正确。所以回到NVIDIA。所以NVIDIA有一个
CUFFT library. You could totally use this to write your own GPU based waved MP3 transcoder. That would be super fast. Yep. Okay, so there's also bindings for CUDA for many languages. It's pretty easy to write your own.
CUFFT库。你完全可以用它来编写你自己的基于GPU的波形MP3转码器。那会超级快。是的。好的，还有很多语言的CUDA绑定。编写你自己的程序非常容易。
OpenCL, a standard, very close to OpenGL in that it supports multiple CPUs and GPUs. Interesting thing there, I said CPUs. It can also, your multi-core processor can be treated just like GPU. So you probably will lose out on doing something specific, but you could approximate something on a computer if someone doesn't have a GPU. Right. And it makes it much easier to debug, too. specific but you could approximate something on a computer if someone doesn't have a gpu right and it makes it much excuse me it makes it much easier to debug too you can actually debug on your cpu catching you know divide by zero errors and things like that and then push it to the gpu once
OpenCL，一个标准，非常接近OpenGL，因为它支持多个CPU和GPU。有趣的是，我说过CPU。它也可以，你的多核处理器可以像GPU一样被对待。所以你可能会在做某些特定事情时失去优势，但如果某人没有GPU，你可以在计算机上近似某些东西。对吧。而且它也让调试变得容易得多。特定，但你可以在计算机上近似某些东西，如果某人没有GPU，对吧，而且它也让调试变得容易得多。你实际上可以在你的CPU上调试，捕捉，你知道，除以零错误之类的东西，然后一旦你确信了就把它推送到GPU，
you're confident and you can support multiple brands of graphics cards right like if somebody you know imagine like you're releasing an app uh you know like some program you want people to download a video game you're writing or who knows right um you know you don't want to just give your game to people with nvidia graphics card you want everyone to have your game and so with opencl it'll use you know nvidia to use ati or i guess they're now amd graphics cards i don't if it doesn't have any of those graphics cards, it can fall back to the CPU, and so it's much more versatile. Similarly, my experience has been
你可以支持多个品牌的显卡，对吧，就像如果某人，你知道，想象一下你正在发布一个应用程序，你知道，比如你正在编写的一个程序，你希望人们下载一个电子游戏，或者谁知道呢，对吧，你知道，你不想只把你的游戏给有NVIDIA显卡的人，你希望每个人都有你的游戏，所以有了OpenCL，它会使用，你知道，NVIDIA，使用ATI，或者我想它们现在是AMD显卡了，如果它没有任何这些显卡，它可以回退到CPU，所以它更通用。同样，我的经验是
that they tend to implement things a little slower because it's a standard, so it takes a little longer to get everybody on board. And people tend to prefer their own implementation over the OpenCL, talking about manufacturers. So, you know, NVIDIA will support OpenCL at some level, but it's going
它们实现东西的速度往往慢一点，因为这是一个标准，所以让每个人都加入需要更长的时间。而且人们往往更喜欢他们自己的实现而不是OpenCL，谈论制造商。所以，你知道，NVIDIA会在某种程度上支持OpenCL，但它会
to support cuda better and so that also causes some problems yep yeah totally well that's pretty much it i it was a high level we had a little bit of a venture off into fourier land yeah we started with origami and we ended with fast fourier transform so this is definitely an awesome show all right well we've been getting emails still people were wondering where the show went we've had busy lives having uh jason had a kid i had a kid so there are two more people in the world who want will want to listen to the podcast yeah maybe or not yeah we both had children in the past what two months no three months four months i don't know okay anyways it's all become kind of a blur yes we're definitely we probably get eight hours of sleep between the two of us on a good day yeah on a good day um but you know our our kids are
更好地支持CUDA，所以这也导致了一些问题。是的，完全正确。好吧，这差不多就是这样了，这是一个高层概述，我们稍微冒险进入了傅里叶领域。是的，我们从折纸开始，最后以快速傅里叶变换结束，所以这绝对是一个很棒的节目。好的，好吧，我们一直在收到电子邮件，人们仍然想知道节目去哪了，我们生活很忙，杰森有了孩子，我也生了孩子，所以世界上又多了两个人想听这个播客。是的，也许吧，或者不。是的，我们俩在过去两个月，不，三个月，四个月，我不知道，都生了孩子。好吧，无论如何，这一切都变得有点模糊了。是的，我们肯定，我们两人加起来在好日子里可能睡八个小时。是的，在好日子里，但是你知道，我们的孩子
getting like how old is your like four months now four five months five months and mine's almost four months and so now we're starting to get our lives back. A little. And as part of our lives include doing this show for you guys. So definitely thanks for all the love and support. And hey, when you guys are doing an episode, that's really actually good that it sort of motivates us. Yeah, keeps us honest. Yeah, definitely. So we appreciate all the support. Thanks for looking at the books.
长大了，比如你的孩子现在多大了，四个月？五个月，五个月。我的快四个月了，所以现在我们开始找回我们的生活了。一点点。作为我们生活的一部分，包括为你们做这个节目。所以绝对感谢所有的爱和支持。嘿，当你们做一集节目时，这实际上真的很好，它激励了我们。是的，让我们保持诚实。是的，绝对。所以我们感谢所有的支持。感谢你们看书。
I haven't looked at the numbers lately but uh there's a good amount of people buying the books we're recommending which is great because at least clicking on the link and then buying something else which also helps that works too but yeah i mean all of these books are ones that we've read they're not both of us but but the one who's recommending the book is right and uh it's really good that you guys are getting into it too so all right till next time see you later the intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work.
我最近没看数字，但有很多人在买我们推荐的书，这很好，因为至少点击链接然后买别的东西也有帮助，这也行，但我的意思是，所有这些书都是我们读过的，不是我们俩都读过，但推荐书的人读过，而且你们也开始读这些书真的很好，所以好的，下次见，再见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品。
But you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和帕特里克的出处，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。